Ich poste falsche Informationen auf der Web.
Jemand nimmt eine Strasse falscher Informationen, spreadt sie um und bevor du sie weißt, dass du es weißt, eine Panik ist erbaut. Dann wirst du einfach zurück und siehst den Chaos.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express Ausgabe Nummer 90. Wir rasen auf die Hunde zu, aber es dauert noch ein bisschen bis wir so weit sind. Hallo, hier ist Tim Pritlove und ja, ihr habt wieder zugeschaltet bei dem in letzter Zeit etwas seltener erscheinenden Programm. Hier aus meinem Wohnzimmer oder Arbeitszimmer oder was auch immer auf jeden Fall von zu Hause, wo die Gäste immer vor sich hin schnaufen und schon darauf warten, ganz aufgeregt endlich dann zugeschaltet zu werden. Ihr seid ja schon on air hier. Was haben wir denn heute? 7. Juli 2008 und es ist ein kerniges Thema, das liegt vor uns. Ein Thema, was ich schon lange vor mir hergeschoben habe, was natürlich 38 Millionen Mal bereits nachgefragt worden ist, insbesondere, wo es in letzter Zeit so viele Podcasts über Programmiersprachen, Programmiersysteme und überhaupt viele Programmiererei ging. Es wird schon ein richtiger Programmierer-Podcast durchfasst. Soll es aber eigentlich gar nicht sein, sondern hier ist Bandbreite möglichst breit angesagt. Und jetzt sage ich erstmal Hallo zu Boggle.
Hallo. Hallo.
Und Dirk. Hallo. Auch Hallo. Und ja, euch beide habe ich jetzt mal dazu geladen, um den schwierigen Versuch zu unternehmen, das Thema Java richtig unter die Lupe zu nehmen. Ja, wollen wir gleich anfangen oder wollen wir noch sinnloses Zeug reden?
Erzähl doch noch ein bisschen sinnloses Zeug.
Ja, wir haben uns natürlich auch ein bisschen die Köpfe zerbrochen, wie man diesem Thema gerecht werden kann. Java steht ja auf der einen Seite immer sehr im Feuer. Das kann man, glaube ich, schon mal vorweg sagen. Eine sehr umstrittene Plattform, auch eine sehr umstrittene Programmiersprache, die aber nichtsdestotrotz eine große Zahl an Anhängern gefunden hat und die vor allem viel benutzt wird. Also es ist vor allem interessant, dass einfach die Dinge, die immer besonders verschrien sind, da scheinen sich dann auch immer besonders viele Leute dahinter zu scharen. Also man kann über Cobold und Visual Basic sagen, was man will, aber es ist nicht totzukriegen und eine Herrscher von Leuten benutzt das halt regelmäßig. Jetzt will ich das nicht unbedingt da in eine Linie ziehen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch so, dass Java immer sehr viel Kritik hat einstecken müssen aus vielen, vielen unterschiedlichen Gründen, aber trotzdem einfach eine extrem populäre Geschichte geworden. Würdet ihr mir da zustimmen?
Also laut Tiobe-Index ist Java auf Platz 1 seit zumindest 2007.
Was für ein Index ist das?
Das ist so eine Erwähnung von Java in Webseiten, das ist, glaube ich. Kennst du den Tiobe-Index nicht? www.tiobe.com.
Ne, den kenne ich nicht.
Und C ist auf Platz 2 mit 15%, also 6% dahinter.
In irgendwelchen Webseiten oder in bestimmten Webseiten?
Ich weiß es auch nicht ganz genau.
Ich glaube, der ist zusammengesetzt aus mehreren Sachen.
Du glaubst der Statistik einfach.
Ja, die ist gut, die Statistik.
Die wird viel zitiert, die muss gut sein.
Ja, vielleicht fangen wir doch mal so an, nochmal für die Leute, für die Java jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Kernthema ist, auch nochmal einen Blick darauf zu werfen, wo Java nun eigentlich herkommt. Aber bevor wir das machen, könnt ihr vielleicht mal zu euch nochmal was sagen, was so euer Hintergrund ist, damit die Leute sich da auch ein bisschen drauf einstellen können, aus welcher Ecke ihr so geschossen kommt.
Ja, dann fange ich mal an. Tja, also ich bin Boggle, habe Informatik studiert, aber ziemlich lange für das schöne Studium gebraucht und nebenher eine ganze Menge immer gejobbt und da sehr viel mit Java zu tun gehabt. Eigentlich auch schon zu Schulzeit ein bisschen was mit Java gemacht, viel im Enterprise-Bereich, so Integration von größeren Unternehmensanwendungen untereinander. Daher ist so mein Java-Background. Und ja, mittlerweile habe ich mich nochmal entschieden, eine Doktorarbeit zu schreiben und mache jetzt viel mit verteilten Systemen und Peer-to-Peer und solchen Geschichten. Und habe da teilweise auch mit Java zu tun.
Teilweise?
Teilweise. Na ja, also wenn man sich halt den Code, also sehr viele, sehr viele verteilte Systeme, da ist halt der Code in Java geschrieben, also wenn man sich die halt anguckt, distributed hash-Table-Implementation oder so, da gibt es halt unglaublich viel in Java. Und sovon hat man da immer mal wieder mit zu tun.
Zwangsläufig sozusagen?
Ja, so ein bisschen zwangsläufig, genau.
Was da auch eine Menge aussagt darüber, wie verbreitet das ist. Das war zum Beispiel auch immer meine Feststellung, dass man Java einfach sehr häufig im Forschungsbereich antrifft, wo Leute Referenzimplementierungen machen, zum Beispiel von neuen Standards, dass dort Java aufgrund seiner Plattform-Neutralität gerne genommen wird, weil man eben sicherstellen kann, dass solche Referenzimplementierungen dann aber auch wirklich überall laufen.
Ja, es gibt da noch einen ganz anderen Aspekt daran. Ich meine, Code ist ja vor allen Dingen dazu, da gelesen zu werden und Java können viele Leute lesen. Das wird an den Unis gelehrt und das ist natürlich ein nicht zu unterschätzender Vorteil.
An der Stelle ist Java ein bisschen das neue C.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Und du, Dirk?
Also ich an der Uni war, gab es da noch kein Java. Bei mir kam das erst 1998, da habe ich angefangen, Web-Applikationen in Java zu programmieren, also mit Web-Objects habe ich Java gelernt. Und 1999, 2000 habe ich dann mit Surflits weiter, also hauptsächlich Web-Anwendungen. Und erst seit zwei Jahren mache ich so ein bisschen mehr Middleware oder Backend, oder wie man das nennt, also ein bisschen hinter dem Surflit-Layer.
Aber ihr seid beide mehr so auf der Maschinenseite, sage ich mal, nicht so sehr auf der anderen Seite beim Benutzer. Java ja auch nicht so viele Freunde gefunden hat, wie auf der Rückseite der Maschine. Kann man festhalten.
Server-seitiges Java ist schon sehr viel attraktiver.
Gut, super. Na dann, erklär mir noch mal einer, wo das eigentlich herkommt, die Idee mit dem Java. Also, wo hättest du das denn einfallen lassen?
Na, soweit ich mich erinnere, war das wohl in den frühen 90ern so. Das passt eigentlich ganz schön. Java ist eigentlich eine Sprache der 90er. Das passt sehr schön zum Chaos-Radio Express 90, finde ich.
Was, ist das auch ein Podcast der 90er, oder wie?
Das hast du gesagt, wegen der Nummer.
Zur Ausgabe 90, okay, alles klar.
Zur Ausgabe 90, nee. Also, irgendwann in den frühen 90ern hat Sun an so einer Set-Top-Box-Geschichte gewerkelt und brauchten dafür eine Programmiersprache, die von dem Hardwarelehrer abstrahiert. Und in dem Zusammenhang haben die damals Java entwickelt, aber das Projekt war eigentlich gar nicht so erfolgreich. Was dann aber parallel irgendwie plötzlich ganz unglaublich boomte, war eben das World Wide Web. Und dann kam halt diese Idee auch, wir möchten auf der Client-Seite Anwendungscode ausführen können. Und da gab es dann diese Idee der Java-Upletts, sprich, dass man halt Java-Klassen auf den Client rüber lädt und da die von einem Plugin ausgeführt werden. Und im Zusammenhang mit dieser Entwicklung ist halt Java sehr ins Rampenlicht gerückt und dann halt auch gewachsen im Laufe der Jahre. Also, das ist so das, woran ich mich erinnere. Für mich war das damals so an der Schule. Wir haben da mit der Uni so ein bisschen zusammengearbeitet und da meinte irgendwie der eine Mensch da von der Uni, mit dem wir da was gemacht haben, meinte, ja, da gibt es so diese neue Programmiersprache und guck dir die mal an und Java und das wird das nächste große Ding. Und das war ganz schrecklich eigentlich damals. Das war noch Zeiten, die Versionsnummer hieß, glaube ich, HotJava 03 Alpha oder so was, mit der ich da mal gestartet bin. Und das ist noch alle fünf Minuten abgestürzt und hat unglaubliche Ressourcen gefressen, um dann so ein kleines wackelndes Männchen auf dem Display anzuzeigen. Aber das ist die Vergangenheit und das hat sich ja dann doch sehr erstaunlich durchgesetzt und ist eben zusammen mit dem Internetboom gewachsen in den 90ern.
Ja, und was man sich nicht so recht mehr vorstellen kann, ist, dass allein das da überhaupt irgendwas gezuppelt hat im Webbrowser war schon außergewöhnlich so. Jaja, da hat man echt gestauert und so, oh, guck mal, hier, da bewegt sich was. Aber es war halt slow. Aber Java war ja nun extrem gewagt in der Hinsicht. Java läuft in einer virtuellen Maschine. Das hat sich damals eigentlich keiner so recht getraut. Also virtuellen Maschinen an sich waren jetzt nicht unbedingt vollständig unbekannt, aber mir fällt jetzt so nichts ein. Oder gibt es irgendwas, was so damals halbwegs populär war und was sich auch einer virtuellen Maschine bedient hat?
Ja gut, also die Lisp-Fans würden jetzt natürlich wieder die Lisp-Maschine ausgraben. Aber das ist ja irgendwie in den 80ern zusammen mit der Artificial-Intelligence-Forschung in den USA irgendwie auch gestorben. Von daher, ich hoffe, dafür werde ich nicht erschlagen für die Bemerkung.
Und dieses Ne, aber du musst dir einen Hinweis auf ein Chaos-Radio Express vor kurzem nochmal gefallen lassen, wo Hans durchaus eine abweichende Meinung präsentiert hat. Stimmt dir sicherlich zu, dass es bei heutzutage nicht mehr so besonders populär ist. Aber gestorben ist es definitiv nicht. Chaos-Radio Express 84 für die Leute, die das interessiert haben, obwohl ich das Gefühl habe, das haben die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich sowieso schon gehört, so viele Leute, die da eingeschaltet haben.
Ich habe den auch gehört.
Du hast den auch gehört. Und?
Das begegnet mir jetzt auch immer wieder mal. Und ich suche gerade Lesbik.
Hast du da was beilernen können bei dem Podcast?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich kann mich aber nicht mehr so gut erinnern. Ich könnte jetzt nichts zitieren.
Aber Java hat auf jeden Fall dieses Konzept der virtuellen Maschine, da vor allem im Hinblick auf, was waren denn so die Schwerpunkte? Also eben dieses, kann im Webbrowser laufen, ist ja schon mal vor allem der Aspekt, wir sind plattformneutral. Das stand, glaube ich, ganz, ganz klar im Vordergrund. Das ist ja bei Lesbiks nicht so im Vordergrund. Und naja, ich weiß ja nicht, ob der Webbrowser der beste Ort war dafür. Aber bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal so bei Java.
Na im Webbrowser ist es ja quasi auch gescheitert. Also jetzt versuchen sie es gerade wieder zu beleben mit einem schnellen Plugin, was irgendwie Sachen nachlädt, wenn man sie braucht und so weiter. Also es ist jetzt gerade vielleicht die Wende für Java.
Technisch.
Ja, aber das ist noch nicht sicher.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz erstaunlich, weil es ist eben mit dem Web gewachsen, dann gescheitert, aber dann im Backend großgeworden. Das ist ja eigentlich ein bisschen wie ein Phoenix aus der Asche. Also mit den Uplets ist es großgeworden, hat die Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, dann haben Leute das im Backend eingesetzt, dann sind die Uplets gescheitert und die Sprache war trotzdem weiterhin da. Das ist schon eigentlich eine ganz bemerkenswerte Entwicklung.
Aber es gibt ganz klare Gründe dafür. Also im Backend kann halt besser optimiert werden zur Laufzeit oder wird jetzt besser optimiert. Und bis es optimiert ist, muss es erst mal eine Weile gelaufen sein. Und bei einem Applet will man halt gleich was sehen. Dann muss es gleich funken und dann muss es gleich losgehen. Während im Server kann man durchaus mal fünf Minuten warten, bis die Applikation warm gelaufen ist. Und dann...
Ja, die Launch-Time. Das ist definitiv, wobei ich würde gar nicht mal sagen, jetzt aus meiner Perspektive, dass das das einzige Problem war. Das definitiv, also jetzt im Browser. Aber es hat sicherlich dazu zu beigetragen. Aber vielleicht, bevor wir jetzt auf die Vor- und Nachteile und warum jetzt irgendwas gescheitert oder besonders gut funktioniert hat, kommen. Wollte ich noch mal so ein bisschen hinterfragen, was denn nun eigentlich die Architektur ist. Ich meine, von Anfang an hat Sun mit sehr vielen Buzzwords um sich geschmissen und klar gemacht, dass Java eben sehr viel mehr ist, als nur eine einzige Programmiersprache. Natürlich steht die Java-the-programming-Language im Mittelpunkt, aber dann muss man eben auch noch die Laufzeitumgebung, Virtual Machine haben wir jetzt schon erwähnt, dazu erwähnen, aber es geht ja dann noch weiter, weil Sun ja auch eine komplette Programmierumgebung mit der Sprache mitdefiniert. Also die Laufzeitumgebung ist halt mit APs, vielerlei Art umgehend. Was hat das damals umfasst und wie hat sich das entwickelt?
Also was ist denn so dazugeguckt? JDK 1.0 hatte, soweit ich weiß, schon Thread Support.
Also JDK ist das Java Development Kit, klar.
Und das war schon was Besonderes, also Thread Support in der Sprache oder in den Libraries zu haben. Und es gab IOS-Support, naja, das Nötigste halt. Also JDK 1.0 war noch sehr rudimentär.
War aber dafür eben auch schlank und übersichtlich, was man ja heute manchmal ein bisschen vermisst, wenn man vor den, weiß ich nicht, wie viel, 30 Megabyte Doku, die sie da mittlerweile im Mittellieferhandel sitzt, wenn man da reinschaut. Ja, was ist noch dazugekommen? Später natürlich bei GUI, da hat sich ja einiges getan. Da gab es ja mal den großen Dixel von ABT zu Swing.
Ja, vor allem gab es erst mal dieses ABT. Ich habe am Anfang Java wahrgenommen, der Versuch so, ja, bergbrunst, wir sind jetzt so eine Art Mini-Betriebssystem. Wir haben so ein bisschen GUI, wir haben so ein bisschen rein-raus, wir haben so ein bisschen das Notwendige, was man so zum Programmieren braucht. Threads, hast du schon erwähnt, erlauben halt so die Nebenläufigkeit von Programmen. Und das macht es halt einfach, aber am Ende hatte man noch eigentlich ein System, was einerseits relativ langsam lief, weil einfach damals diese Virtual Machine vorfeld hier schon festgestellt...
Bitte?
Die war damals sogar noch interpretiert tatsächlich.
Ach wirklich?
Vor JIT-Compiler kam, war das...
Ach stimmt, richtig, genau.
Interpretiert.
Stimmt, am Anfang war es ein, genau, und später kamen sie dann mit, ja, jetzt werden wir schneller. Vielleicht war das auch ein strategischer Fehler, überhaupt erst mal so langsam zu sein und nicht gleich so mit so einer Mindest-Performance aufzuschlagen. Aber sie konnten sich wahrscheinlich den Zeitpunkt so recht nicht aussuchen. Sie hatten die Gelegenheit, sich da bei Netscape einzuklinken und das quasi als Marketing-Maßnahme für ihr System zu benutzen. Ich meine, ansonsten wäre Java wahrscheinlich niemanden wirklich jemals wirklich aufgefallen.
Vielleicht hätte es einfach nur länger gedauert, aber das...
Das kann man heute nicht mehr so richtig bewerten. Ja, aber es war ja nicht so viel. Also es war halt so ein bisschen rein raus und ein bisschen, hm, und jetzt malen wir so ein paar Fenster und so. Und so recht überzeugt hat es eigentlich niemanden, habe ich so einen Eindruck gehabt.
Nee, es sah irgendwie immer hässlich aus, ne?
Aber was ist, aber was hat sich denn da jetzt sozusagen daraus entwickelt? Ich meine, mittlerweile gibt es so eine Herrschar von Abkürzungen, die alle mit J anfangen. Wenn man jetzt mal so, nicht jetzt nur in der Geschichte hängen bleibt, sondern jetzt auch mal so sieht, wie hat sich das bis heute entwickelt. Als was muss man, welche Komponenten muss man wahrnehmen, um jetzt zu verstehen, was Java alles umfasst? Wir können sicherlich nicht alles aufzählen, weil das ist wirklich eine lange Liste, aber was sind so die wichtigsten Komponenten, die Java als Plattform ausmachen?
Ja gut, man kann sicherlich das verschieden partitionieren, aber einmal hat man natürlich, was wir hier schon angesprochen haben, diese ganzen Dinge, die Betriebssystem-nahe Funktionalität kapseln. Das sind wie Threads zum Beispiel, irgendwie mal ein externes Kommando aufrufen können, Dateizugriff, diese Dinge. Dann hat man diese ganzen Dinge, die vielleicht eher wichtig sind für die Integration mit irgendwelchen Unternehmensanwendungen im Backend. Das Korbanbindung vielleicht nur mal so als Stichwort, was halt im Backend dann wichtig ist.
Der Common Object Request Broker, die Architecture. Auch eher so ein Failed State in meinen Augen, aber gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Gibt es auf jeden Fall, wird gemacht.
Manchmal braucht man das.
Cross-Platform und auch Cross-Language. Man kann damit Java und C++ anbinden mit Korva.
Klar, aber trotzdem hat ja auch Java seine eigenen Wir-Sprechen-Miteinander-Projekte gehabt. Ganz viele sogar.
Die da auch noch MI und Hash Yank und XML, RPC und was nicht alles.
Dann hat sich da mittlerweile irgendwas rausgeschält.
Man hat halt BNR-Protokolle und OSCQ-Protokolle.
Man hat halt einfach alles.
RMI war ja ganz gut gemeint und wurde auch durchaus benutzt. Man hat gemerkt, wir müssen Körpers supporten, aber eigentlich finden wir das schlimm. Wir versuchen mal noch was daneben zu stellen, was ein bisschen schlanker ist.
Im Prinzip die Fortführung. RPC, das Konzept Remote Procedure Call, das kommt ja auch von Sun. Das ist ja alte Sun-Suppe. Das haben sie im Prinzip dann als Java-Only-System gemacht.
Tja, was kann man noch sagen? Gui, hatten wir schon dann, ja, XML, so eine andere Geschichte, die ja groß wurde in den 90ern, wo irgendwie Java auch die Plattform war, wo die Parser für da waren, die ganzen Referenzimplementationen, Transformationen, also XSLT-Geschichten, was ja auch alles dazugehört. Out of the Box muss man ja auch erstmal alles haben, wenn man irgendeine beliebige Programmiersprache hat.
Man kann ja auch aus eigener Erfahrung berichten, gerade XSLT mit dem Saxon, ganz hervorragendes Stück Software. Also da gibt es nichts besseres, heute noch nicht.
Ja, das ist wahr.
Also im Grunde sind es drei Komponenten, oder? Die Sprache, die Virtual Machine und das JDK und die Libraries. Das sind so die drei Teile, die man da finden soll.
Aber dann gibt es noch dieses JDK in verschiedenen Ausführungen und Paketierungen. Das finde ich immer so ein bisschen verwirrend. Da gibt es eine Mobile-Edition oder so.
Es gibt J2-SI, das ist die Standard-Edition. Das ist das, was man für Anwendungsprogrammierung verwendet.
Und J2 steht für Java 2, was eigentlich …Ja, was mit 1, 2 ist.
So weit ich mich erinnere, war das 1, 2 eigentlich.
Genau.
Und es gibt aber dann das J2, das gibt es dann auch in 1, 3-Flavor, 1, 4, 1, 5 und 1, 6. Das heißt jetzt ja aber nicht …Das heißt immer noch J2.
Aber die Versionsnummer hat sich doch jetzt nochmal geändert, oder?
Also jetzt heißt es nur noch 6, ne? Achso, genau. Also es gibt das SE, das ist sozusagen das, was Standard ist. Dann gibt es J2EE, das ist die Enterprise Edition. Das ist halt Surflits, EJB, Enterprise Java Beans. Das ist so das Enterprise Java Zeugs. Also Enterprise im Sinne von große Unternehmen, die viel Geld haben, brauchen eine teure Software und wollen viel Schulungen machen. Also Surflits sind eigentlich ein sehr einfaches. Also das benutzt man auch, ohne enterpriseig zu sein. Also die Surflit API ist halt die Web API von Java sozusagen.
Also so wie ein Uplet sich damals in die Application, quasi in die Webseite, reingeworfen hat als Mini-Applikation, ist ein Surflit dasselbe Konzept, bloß auf der anderen Seite, auf dem Backend. So dass man halt in einen klar definierten Umgebung seinen Java-Code hineinindiziert und dann ist man Teil des Web-Servers.
Genau, man hat ja die Hooks für Post, Get und mehr gibt es ja eigentlich auch gar nicht bei HTTP. Na, es gibt schon noch ein bisschen mehr, aber man benutzt auch gar nicht die Surflit API selbst, sondern man hat ja in der Regel noch Frameworks obendrauf, die einem das sehr viel erleichtern. Aber unten drunter und man kann es halt als Surflit paketieren. Da sind wir jetzt schon bei Deployment, also da kommt dann ein VAR-File raus, ein Web-Archiv und das kann man halt in beliebige Surflit-Container werfen und dann läuft das da im Idealfall. Also das ist schon praktisch und aber um jetzt noch mal die Pakete fertig zu machen, haben wir J2ME, das ist halt das für Telefone, für Mobile-Telefone.
Was hatten wir denn jetzt bisher? Also wir hatten dieses J2SE.
Genau, Standard-Edition. Kann man sagen, sozusagen die Workstation unter den Jaros.
Und nach der Standard-Edition kommt welche Edition?
Na die Enterprise-Edition, würde ich sagen. Und dann J2ME, das wird die Micro-Edition für Telefone. Und da gibt es noch verschiedene...
Micro heißt das, nicht Mobile?
Echt? Und da gibt es dann verschiedene Profile, nämlich CLDC und CDC. CDC ist für Setup-Boxen, die halt, also Connected Device Configuration heißt das. Also die, die immer Netz haben, während diese Mobiltelefone, die haben ja nicht immer Netz, sondern nur manchmal, das ist dann CLDC, also Connected Limited Device Configuration. Und dann gibt es noch MIP1 und MIP2, also MIP ist dann die Mobile Ruby, da kommen wir jetzt nicht. M-I-D-P? M-I-D-P ist, da kommen dann die Midlets von M-I-D-P.
Ja, da habe ich auch schon mal was versucht zum Laufen zu kriegen, aber das ist mir nicht gelungen, glaube ich.
Da sind wir auch schon mitten im Java-Buzzword-Land, also das ist schon sehr auffallend in dieser Umgebung, dass man doch schon einen unglaublichen Wildwuchs an APIs und Libraries und Frameworks hat.
Extrem viele ETLAs vor allem, irgendwie alles vierbuchstabig.
Ah, genau. Also die Midlets zum Beispiel, die haben nämlich keine Reflection. Während das J2SE hat und J2EE, also die Enterprise Edition, hat Reflection, das bedeutet, man kann zur Laufzeit erstens, man kriegt eine Klasse und kann sie fragen, was für Methoden hast du eigentlich? Und was für Felder hast du eigentlich? Was kann ich mit dir machen? Wie heißt du eigentlich? Also das ist Reflection und das gibt es halt bei...
Das gab es doch auch nicht von Anfang an bei Java, oder?
Ich glaube, Reflection gab es schon von Anfang an. Also mindestens, ich glaube mindestens in einer 1.1. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob in einer 1.0 schon Reflection drin war.
1.1 würde ich auch sagen, ja 1.0 wüsste ich es auch nicht. Das war, bevor ich mich mit sowas beschäftigt habe, muss ich sagen.
Also ich habe mich auch erst ab 1.2 damit beschäftigt.
Okay, also, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen. Also Java kommt erstmal als Sprache und kommt in einer Edition. Und vor allem kommt es erstmal in der Standard Edition. Das heißt, Java Standard Edition, wenn ich mir das installiere auf irgendeinem Computer oder wenn ein System von sich behauptet, dieses zu haben, was habe ich dann? Dann habe ich die virtuelle Maschine, dann habe ich einen Java-Compiler. Ich meine, gehört die Developer-Umgebung sozusagen zu?
Genau, das JDK ist die Developer-Umgebung und das JRE, R-E, das ist das Runtime-Environment. Also du kannst hier, wenn du das JRE installierst, kannst du Java ausführen und wenn du das JDK noch zusätzlich installierst oder im JDK ist auch ein JRE immer mit drin, dann kannst du auch entwickeln. Da ist ein Compiler zum Beispiel dabei.
Da gibt es dann jeweils eine Variante jeweils für diese Edition oder was? Also es gibt ein JRE, ein Runtime-Environment für die Standard Edition oder für die Enterprise Edition oder ist das Runtime-Environment immer dasselbe?
Also die Enterprise Edition ist auch nur ein Zusatz zur Standard Edition eigentlich. Also da kriegst du noch mehr Apis dazu. Da ist jetzt keine eigene Virtual Machine dabei, sondern nur Apis.
Aber im Falle dieser mobilen Geräte, die dann irgendwie bestimmte Features nicht mehr haben, frage ich mich, ob dann die Runtime auch anders ist. Also jetzt so für Embedded-Devices und kleine Mobil-Devices.
Da ist die Runtime anders, limitiert.
Das heißt, es gibt schon Edition-spezifische Runtimes. Und Standard und Enterprise teilen sich da vielleicht einer, aber die ganzen Mobile, es gibt da auch noch mal so eine Entflechtung grundsätzlich in, ich bin ein richtiger Computer und ich bin irgendwie ein schwachbrustiges System. Kann man das so sagen?
Das kann man so sagen. Wobei bei der J2SE bzw. IE hat man ja dann innerhalb der Runtime sogar noch mal die Möglichkeit, zwischen der eingesetzten Virtual Machine, zwischen Server und Client-Modus umzuschalten. Also selbst da spaltet das sich dann noch einmal auf.
Ach und was ist da der Unterschied?
Da führt die Optimierung in einer anderen Art und Weise durch.
Also wenn man Java-Minus-Server startet, dann dauert es länger mit dem Hochfahren. Dafür wird es immer besser. Also es wird noch während es läuft weiter optimiert. Und besser optimiert. Es wird mehr Energie reingesteckt sozusagen.
Optimiert on the fly.
Genau. Also die Client-Version ist darauf optimiert, schneller zu starten und optimiert auch noch. Also es ist auch ein JIT, auch ein Just-In-Time-Compiler und auch Hotspot. Aber es wird mehr darauf geachtet, dass es schnell startet.
Was meinst du mit auch Hotspot?
Hotspot heißt, dass häufig benutzte Stellen besser optimiert werden. Also da läuft eine Schleife einmal durch, dann merkt er, oh, die läuft jetzt noch 1.000 Mal durch, dann optimiere ich die mal besser, was da drin passiert. Das ist Hotspot. Ganz kurz gesagt.
So viel Zeit haben wir nur auch nicht.
Also da sind noch sehr viel mehr Optimierungen, die müssen wir noch optimieren.
Okay, ich versuche es nochmal ein bisschen gerade zurück, weil mich hat das auch mal ausreichend verwirrt. Also wir haben diese Standard-Edition, Enterprise-Edition, Mobile-Edition. Und in allen wirkt irgendwie ein Runtime, was je nach Edition unterschiedlich optimiert ist und mal auch die eine und die andere Option bietet. Und für alles gibt es jeweils dann noch ein entsprechendes Development-Kit, das JDK, sodass man dann in diesem Edition sozusagen auch programmieren kann. Und die Editions unterscheiden sich für den Programmierer im Wesentlichen. Dadurch, dass bestimmte Features dann zusätzlich da sind bzw. nicht vorhanden sind bei einer kleineren Randteilumgebung. Ist das ganz richtig?
Ja, das ist ganz okay.
Und das ist eigentlich erstmal das, was man verstehen muss, um grundsätzlich diese Plattformfrage für sich zu erschließen. Oder gibt es noch irgendeinen anderen großen Schlüssel, den man unbedingt in die Hand nehmen muss, um zu verstehen, was man überhaupt so installieren muss? Also ich fand das nämlich immer extrem verwirrend. Bevor Sun sich entschlossen hat, das zu GPL und Open Source zu machen, wobei ich ehrlich gesagt, seitdem habe ich es noch nicht ausprobiert, aber man war ja immer gezwungen, wenn man irgendwas Java-haftiges hatte, wurde man dann von allen Installationssystemen dann immer so zu Sun geschickt. Und jetzt musst du bei Sun dir das runterladen, das Richtige und installieren. Kein Automatismus, da kam dann irgendwie die Copyright-Klausel. Und dann stand man so vor diesen Sun-Webseiten und hat sich gefragt, was jetzt bitte? Ja, das war so schlimm. Überall stand J und alles war so J-Sprache. Total Gaga. Ich habe diese Welt nicht verstanden. Ich war in Java-Land, alles war ein Kaffeeboden. Und alles fing mit Java an und alles fing mit J an, sodass man eigentlich gar nichts auseinanderhalten konnte. Das war zumindest so meine Erfahrung. Hat sich das jetzt irgendwie verbessert?
Vielleicht mit der nächsten Version. In Ubuntu gibt es schon einen Java mitgeliefert. Insofern ist es wenigstens schon mal bei diesem Ubuntu dabei. Ich hatte auch Probleme mit BSD. Und jetzt kriege ich mal einen Java für BSD. Und zwar ein aktuelles. Nicht irgendwie 1.0, 1.2, 1.3, sondern ich wollte halt 1.5 haben. Und das hieß dann jedes Mal bei jeder Kiste, die ich installiert habe, erstmal die Binary von Sun holen, dann die Patches von Z holen und dann erstmal alles zusammenwerfen und dann am Schluss hoffentlich ein, nein, dann haben wir es noch ein Linux-emuliertes Java vorher holen, damit man es überhaupt bauen kann. Und das war wirklich nicht schön. Also selbst für jemanden, der damit Erfahrung hat, war es unpraktisch.
Gut, andererseits, ich meine für die 95% der meisten Nutzer, die zu Sun gehen und sich das downloaden wollen, die sind einfach mit der Standard-Edition gut bedient. Und alle, die was anderes brauchen, wissen das im Normalfall. Also wenn man im Mobile-Bereich unterwegs ist, die Mobile-Edition braucht, da kommt man noch dahinter. Und im Enterprise-Bereich, die Enterprise-Edition. Also wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, kann man da schon dahinter kommen. Aber man muss eben wissen, dass das Java 2, die Standard-Edition und das dazugehörige SDK eigentlich das ist, wenn man damit starten will, dass man sich mal ziehen sollte und sich angucken sollte. Umgekehrt, manche Plattformen haben es natürlich auch ein bisschen bequemer als Mac-Nutzer. Es ist zumindest das Rant-Time und die Standard-Edition vorinstalliert. Da muss man sich gar nicht weiter anstrengen. Und ich glaube, das JDK ist sogar mit auf den Developer-CDs drauf. Weiß ich gar nicht genau aus dem Kopf, woher man sich das ziehen musste.
Bei Mac?
Ja, das JDK ist schon dabei.
Das ist einfach dabei. Das ist einfach dabei, ne? Ja, ja.
Ich vergesse das immer.
Sie sind da nicht immer top aktuell, was das aktuelle Release betrifft. Sondern Sie bauen das ein bisschen später ein. Aber es liegt auch daran, dass Apple relativ viel Anpassungen vornimmt an das OS. Und natürlich nicht mit dem Release-Schedule von Sun mithalten können. Also wenn die da was rauswerfen, dann heißt das noch lange nicht, dass Apple genug Zeit gehabt hat, das anzupassen. Aber in der Regel kommt es nach. Ich meine, Java ist auf dem Macintosh nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Eine Zeit lang war es ja so, dass Apple strategisch draufgesetzt hat, wie auch immer sie das gemeint haben. Also eine Weile lang haben sie ja sogar gesagt, ja, hier, man kann sogar native Anwendungen entwickeln auf dem Mac. Das hat bloß irgendwie kein Mensch gemacht. Und irgendwann hat es halt auch Apple fallen gelassen. Ich vermute mal einfach deshalb, weil sie eigentlich wussten, dass man mit Objective-C halt mehr machen kann, weil es halt eine dynamische Sprache ist, was Java einfach nicht ist. Also man musste so dermaßen viel von Hand machen, wo man eben bei Objective-C nichts machen musste. Dass es eigentlich echt anstrengend war. Kann man darüber mutmaßen, wie das auch immer ist. Tatsache ist, wo ist denn Java nun wirklich verbreitet? Also wo ist es denn stark? Im Serverbereich. Ich meine jetzt Betriebssysteme. Worauf fährt man denn Java erfolgreich? Muss man jetzt nur noch auf Solaris, und ist wieder bei Sun zu Hause und gut ist?
Also bei Solaris ist es auf jeden Fall dabei. Und da sind, soweit ich das verstanden habe, sogar die Prozessoren inzwischen Java-optimiert. Also diese 32 Kern, hast du nicht gesehen? Jagara heißen die, glaube ich. Die sind halt gut für viele Threads da. Nicht so gut für Floating Point. Aber Linux ist auch sehr gut für Java-Deployment.
Das setzt du auch ein?
Das setzt die Firma ein, in der ich arbeite. Und zwar ausschließlich.
Das läuft ja stabil und zuverlässig.
Das habe ich auch nur rund um gute Erfahrung. Also Java auf Windows kann man auf jeden Fall machen.
Nur BSD ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Genau, aber das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich auch besser werden. Also da bin ich jetzt nicht auf dem neuesten Stand. Ich habe jetzt schon lange kein Java mehr auf BSD installiert.
Ja, Java auf Windows kann ich nicht viel zu sagen. Habe ich außer Kleinseitig noch nie wirklich gemacht.
Ja, wird Kleinseitig gerne benutzt. Aber serverseitig wäre Windows nicht meine erste Wahl.
Was ist denn jetzt so das aktuelle Java? Und das muss man auch benutzen oder das verwenden alle? Oder verwenden alle ganz viele unterschiedliche Versionen von Java?
Es verwenden sogar noch einige 1.4.2. Und wenn man so eine installierte Basis hat, dann will man nicht unbedingt migrieren. Wobei von 1.4.0 zu 1.5.0 lohnt es sich schon für die Programmierer zwischen 1.5.0 und 1.6.0.
Und 1.6.0 ist dann Java 6. Also irgendwann haben sie die 1.0 einfach fallen gelassen, weil das nicht gut klingt.
So ungefähr. Und ich meine, was man generell vielleicht sagen kann von Sun, was sie immer gemacht haben, was sicherlich auch ein Teil des Erfolges darstellt, ist, dass sie Rückwärtskompatibilität ganz gut im Griff haben. Seid auch teilweise zum Kreuz, weil halt bestimmte Sachen nie gefixt werden. Aber im Großen und Ganzen tut Sun eher Sachen dazu, als dass sie alte Sachen rausschmeißen. Was eben den Vorteil hat, wenn ich mir einen Java 6 installiere, kann ich trotzdem in der Regel 1.4er-Programme laufen lassen oder 1.5er-Programme.
Ohne den Bytecode von 1.4er und 1.5er. Also ich muss es nicht noch mal kompilieren, sondern ich kann den Bytecode laufen lassen.
Ach so, der Bytecode hat sich geändert?
Ja, in jeder Version.
In jeder Version?
Nein, das Class-Format wird immer eine Version hochgezählt. Wir sind jetzt, glaube ich, bei 50 gerade. Das merkt man dann, wenn man versucht, ein mit Java 6 kompiliertes auf Java 5 laufen zu lassen. Das geht nämlich nicht. Man kann die neuen kompilierten Class-Folds nicht auf alten JVMs laufen lassen.
Aber andersrum?
Andersrum geht es.
Auch unlimitiert.
Und es lohnt sich auch, weil die JVMs immer schneller geworden sind. Java 6 ist hauptsächlich schneller geworden zu Java 5. Es gibt kaum Sprachänderungen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es hier in den Class-Folds doch...
Auch noch mit alten Binary. Also Java 6 führt auch an Java 1 Binary schneller aus als eine Java 1 Binary.
Das ist eh ganz drollig, wie die Optimierung passiert. Das ist so, dass der Java C-Compiler eigentlich schon mal voroptimiert. So, der macht so ein paar Sachen. Und die Optimierungen werden dann beim Laden der Class-Folds wieder komplett rückgängig gemacht.
Also mit Java C-Compiler meinst du den Java-Compiler, dessen Kommandozeile Java C ist.
Genau. Also der macht schon so einen Compiler, der optimiert ja den Code und versucht das halt so ein bisschen zu beschleunigen alles. Und de facto, ich hab das auch erst vor einer Weile gelesen, wusste das auch nicht, de facto ist es so, dass dann, wenn das in die Java VM geladen wird, werden quasi diese Optimierungen wieder rückgängig gemacht, mehr oder weniger. Und dann passiert die eigentliche Optimierung erst durch den Just-in-Time-Compiler und die Hotspot-Engine.
Was ist denn die Hotspot-Engine?
Na, das ist ja so ein gewisses Alleinstellungsmerkmal auch der Java VM gewesen. Was sie halt machen, ist, dass sie zur Laufzeit gucken, welche Stellen von Code besonders viel benutzt werden und dann, basierend auf dieser statistischen Information, entscheiden, wo optimiert werden muss. Weil das ganze JDK5, da kam es ja schon mal kurz, ist halt sehr groß. Man könnte nicht das komplett in einen nativen Code für den Prozessor übersetzen, oder es würde alles viel zu lange dauern und die Start-up-Time ist gerade auf dem Client-Jahn-Thema. Deswegen macht man es eher so, dass man guckt, wo sind die inneren Schleifen, wo sind die Code-Stückchen, die viel benutzt werden, und die werden eben zur Laufzeit optimiert.
Das betrifft dann jetzt nicht nur das eigene Programm, das man laufen lässt, sondern im Prinzip auch alle Bibliotheken, die man nutzt. Das heißt, diese Hotspot-Engine stellt fest, oh, alles klar, hier wird jetzt viel mit, was weiß ich, AVT, Schnickschnack, XML-Parsing gemacht, dann greift das an der Stelle mehr.
Na, für JLK wird alles optimiert, ja. Also es gibt keinen optimierten Zustand, der gecached wird, soweit ich weiß jedenfalls.
Nee, ich glaube, für JLK gibt es den mittlerweile. Dadurch kriegen sie auch die Start-up-Time besser hin. Also für die Standard-Edition, nicht für JLK. Aber für die Sun-eigenen Core-Libraries, da gibt es was, wodurch sie die Start-up-Time runterkriegen.
Was ist denn so mit dem alten Vorwurf, dass Java langsam ist? Stimmt das?
Java ist nicht langsam.
Sondern?
Ich habe mir noch einen Spickzettel gemacht. Zum Beispiel ist es nicht mehr interpretiert. Das hatten wir schon. Es wird in Maschinencode umgesetzt. Der Vorteil von der JIT-Engine ist, dass es auf den Prozessor, auf dem es läuft, optimiert werden kann. Wenn ich ein C-Programm kompiliere, dann kompiliere ich das für eine Plattform. Aber der Prozessor selbst kann durchaus einige Vorteile haben, die nicht genutzt werden können, weil man nicht wissen kann, wo man laufen wird. Man kann zur Laufzeit noch Optimierungen vornehmen, die sonst unter Umständen nicht gehen. Dann ist es auch nicht mehr so, dass Objekte unbedingt auf dem Heap alloziert werden müssen. Es gibt auch Verfahren in Java 6, dass Objekte auf dem Stack erzeugt werden können. Die Synchronisierung ist nicht unbedingt langsam, weil sie auch wegoptimiert werden kann. Wenn nur Objekte thread-local verwendet werden, kann da kein anderer Thread zugreifen. Dann kann man die Synchronisierung ausschalten, wenn man sie nicht braucht. Garbage Collection ist auch nicht langsam, sondern teilweise sogar schneller als von Hand Speicher zu allozieren oder freizugeben. Beim Allozieren ist es schneller, weil die Java VM sich gleich einen ganzen Batzen Speicher krallt. In diesem Batzen, für alles, was auf der Stande hieb, wird dann alloziert. Dann muss nur ein Zeiger hochgesetzt werden, ab wo wieder was frei ist. Das geht schneller, als durchs Betriebssystem durchzugehen und zu sagen, gib mir mal 5 Kilo Byte und gib mir noch mal 5 Kilo Byte.
Aber das läuft auch eigentlich so bei C mit M-A-Log auch nicht so sehr anders.
Das sind auf jeden Fall mehr Instruktionen, die man für M-A-Log braucht.
Okay, ich weiß, dass zumindest die Garbage Collection keinen unnötigen Overhead macht. Ich habe auch mehrere Untersuchungen gesehen, aber ich könnte die jetzt nicht wiedergeben, wo relativ klar dargelegt wurde, dass Garbage Collection nicht nur nicht langsamer sein muss, sondern unter manchen Bedingungen sogar die Möglichkeit bietet, schneller zu sein, weil man einfach Optimierung vornehmen kann.
Also einerseits bei der Alozierung.
Wenn man es sonst von Hand machen müsste, die in der Regel aber keiner macht.
Und bei der Dealozierung ist es sogar noch besser, weil die aktuellen Garbage-Collektoren, die arbeiten so, dass sie den Teil, den sie benutzen können, also nicht der Garbage-Collector, sondern der, der den Speicher haben will, der benutzt nur die Hälfte von dem Speicher, den er benutzen darf. Und viele Objekte sterben jung, also die meisten, so 90 Prozent ungefähr, und die, die jung sterben, die müssen dann nicht in die andere Hälfte kopiert werden, wenn der Garbage-Collector läuft. Also es werden nur die Objekte kopiert in die andere Hälfte des Speicherbereichs, die tatsächlich gebraucht werden.
Und die eine Weile Bestand haben.
Genau, die es überlebt haben, wenn der Garbage-Collector zuschlägt. Und die, die sozusagen schon nicht mehr referenziert werden, da kostet es einfach nichts, die frei zu geben, weil der Speicher danach als der andere Hälfte, also die, na jetzt, also er kopiert die, die benutzt werden aus der einen Hälfte in der anderen Hälfte. Und alles, was da noch drin ist, wird sozusagen nicht gebraucht und ist frei. Und da kann dann wieder neu alloziert werden. Insofern ist die Deallokation sogar gratis für die jungsterbenden Objekte.
Das heißt, die Performance hat sich doch deutlich gebessert bei Java?
Auf jeden Fall. Also um nochmal so einen anderen Ding anzuschneiden, was man auch immer mal gerne hört, dass Java und IO irgendwie gar nicht gehen würde. Also sprich, irgendwelche Dinge auf Platte schreiben. Das kommt meistens von Leuten, die halt Java aus der Zeit 112 kennen und die halt die alten Apis kennen, die da auch sicherlich superoptimal waren. Da gibt es aber seit einer ganzen Weile die sogenannten New IO. Klassen, die also auch Hochperformanten IO. Zugriff und solche Dinge wie Unix Select, glaube ich, gehen damit auch und so. Also da hat sich viel getan. Und vielleicht nochmal auch eine zweite Sache zu sagen, die man vielleicht auch sich mal vergegenwärtigen sollte, wenn man sagt, Java ist langsam. Da passiert auch verdammt viel, wenn eine JVM gestartet wird. Das ist eben so ein bisschen, naja, vielleicht die Analogie mit Emacs ist vielleicht gar nicht so dumm. Das ist, als ob man ein halbes Betriebssystem lädt. Das muss man sich halt auch mal klar machen. Also ich meine, wenn da das JDK initialisiert wird und was man da eigentlich alles an Services geboten kriegt, wenn so eine JVM startet, ist ja auch nicht wenig. Und das eigene Betriebssystem muss es ja normalerweise auch machen, wenn ich das starte. Und die Bootzeit, die wird dann halt auch gerne unterschlagen. Also so eine JVM ist schon eine große Umgebung, die geladen wird. Und dass die halt auch ein bisschen Speicher frisst, ja, kommt man halt nicht dran vorbei.
Ja, aber sie muss ja jedes Mal geladen werden, wenn so ein Programm gestartet wird. Das ist natürlich was ganz anderes als so ein Betriebssystem, weil das startet man nur einmal.
Deshalb ist das Server seitdem ja auch so erfolgreich, weil den Server, den startet man halt auch nur einmal, im Idealfall, bis halt die nächste Version installiert wird. Und dann startet man ihn halt nochmal. Und dann machen fünf Minuten, also es ist nicht fünf Minuten. Es sind so zwei Sekunden, bis was läuft. Und bis es dann so richtig rund läuft, kann man schon so ein paar Minuten ansetzen. Also wenn man irgendwie Benchmarks macht, dann sollte man auf jeden Fall der JVM Zeit geben, zu optimieren und die über längere Zeit laufen lassen.
Es gab ja auch mal so die Idee, dass halt die JVM die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund laufen soll. Und dann, ich weiß nicht, was draus geworden ist. Das war glaube ich so ein Randprojekt. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das noch realisieren wollen. Dass man quasi innerhalb der JVM so Sub-JVMs hat, die voneinander komplett abgeschottet sind. Und das ist aber derzeit eben leider nicht gegeben. Deswegen halt man das dann doch immer mal lieber für jede Anwendung neu startet. Wobei teilweise im Backend das halt funktioniert, wenn man da saubere Interfaces hat für die unterschiedlichen Web-Anwendungen. Aber auch da kann man manchmal, wenn man Pech hat, halt irgendwie lustige Effekte erleben, dass sie sich dann eben doch ins Gehege kommen, wenn die in derselben JVM laufen. Ja, also wenn man das machen würde, dann könnte man tatsächlich denselben Effekt haben wie bei den Betriebssystemen, dass man eben die JVM startet, vielleicht sogar mit den Booten des eigenen Betriebssystems und dann halt wie so Capsules oder Sandboxes, weiß nicht, wie man sowas nennen mag, halt auch mehrere Java-Anwendungen parallel ausführen könnte in derselben JVM ohne auf Probleme zu stoßen. Aber das ist derzeit eben nicht gegeben. Oder nicht hinreichend gegeben.
Also vergleichbar zu Prozessen im Betriebssystem.
Genau, das wäre die Analogie hier.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Konzept, das zu machen, aber es scheint auch schwierig zu sein, sonst gäbe es das bestimmt schon.
Kommen wir doch mal so ein bisschen zur Programmiersprache selber. Java ist ja nun kein großer Wurf, was Programmiersprachen betrifft. Also das orientiert sich stark an C. Man kann, glaube ich, festhalten, dass Java eigentlich vor allem von C inspiriert ist. Man hat eine relativ ähnliche Syntax und es versucht vor allem, die ganzen Kernprobleme, die man so an C auszusetzen hatte, zu bereinigen. Also es führt ein Objektsystem hinzu und das ist auch relativ rigide.
Statisch typisiert?
Es ist nach wie vor statisch typisiert. Daran hat sich sozusagen nicht viel geändert, aber immerhin gibt es dieses Objektsystem. Und wie du schon erwähnt hast, es gibt halt Garbage Collection, was natürlich auch so eins der Hauptprobleme bei der C-Programmierung ist, wie wir täglich an Crashing-Applikationen feststellen dürfen.
Aber keine Pointer?
Genau, jetzt vielleicht mal so mit euren Worten. Was sind so die Kernfeatures an Java, an der Programmiersprache, die jetzt Java liebenswert machen für euch? Oder vielleicht auch nicht ganz so liebenswert?
Na ja, ich habe da auch zwei Sichten auf das Ganze. Also in gewisser Weise, wenn man von C++ traumatisiert ist, weil einem das viel zu komplex ist und viel zu unübersichtlich, und das ist ja die häufige Kritik zu C++, dann ist Java in gewisser Weise eine gewisse Erlösung gewesen in den 90er Jahren, weil man hat sich mal auf die Kernfeatures, die man haben möchte, für eine einfache objektorientierte Programmiersprache besonnen. Man hat einfach gesagt, okay, wir wollen Objektorientierung, wir wollen einfache Vererbung. Diese ganze Geschichte mit der Mehrfachvererbung, das ist uns alles viel zu kompliziert. Das machen wir nur auf der Ebene von Interfaces, weil da hat man diese Probleme nicht, die sonst bei Mehrfachvererbung auftreten. Dann nehmen wir Exceptions dazu. Das hatte sich total bewährt im Vergleich dazu, wie man das in C macht mit irgendwelchen Errorcodes, die immer stackframeweise nach oben gereicht werden müssen. Das ist dann auch von gestern. Dann nehmen wir die Syntax von C, weil das können ganz schrecklich viele Leute und wichtige Ideen von Objektorientierung, strenger Datenkapselung und so, und machen daraus mal einen netten kleinen Mix, der eigentlich relativ schnell versteh- und verdaubar ist. Und zu implementieren ist. Das andere, was man sich auch noch angenommen hat, was vielleicht nicht so, man kann sagen, es ist nicht unbedingt die Sprache, aber es spielt auf jeden Fall mit rein, ist, man hat sich auf jeden Fall mal ein Konzept gemacht, wie man irgendwie Malti-Solid-Programmierungen ermöglichen kann. Gut, es ist nicht so unbedingt gelungen, es hat man später nochmal umgestoßen, aber ja, schon Java 1.0 hatte diese Synchronize, das heißt, ich konnte auf beliebige Objekte quasi, die als sowas ähnliches wie ein Log benutzen und hatte diese ganzen Geschichten. Das war auch sehr wichtig, nämlich für diese GUI-Interface-Geschichten in den Java-Uplets. Da hat man das schon, das hat man eigentlich schon für die Uplets gebraucht, die Malti-Thread-Fähigkeit. Da wurde das schon benutzt. So, das ist die eine Seite, dass es sicherlich, durch diesen kleinen Sprachkern, ist es sicherlich auch sehr, sehr beliebt halt als Einstiegssprache in Unis und so, wird es ja immer, wird es ja auch viel benutzt und ob das so eine gute Idee ist, sei dahingestellt, um Erstsemestern halt das Programmieren zu vermitteln. Und man fällt da halt auch nicht so schnell auf die Nase, wenn man irgendwie Java einsetzt, eben weil man eine Garbage Collection hat, weil man irgendwie nicht von irgendwelchen wilden Zeigern und Speicherproblemen erschlagen wird, wenn man mal nur ein einfaches Hello World Programm schreiben will im ersten Kurs. Man ist da schon ein bisschen auf der, man ist ein bisschen mehr behütet in einer Laufzeitumgebung wie Java, als wenn man gleich mit C anfängt. Das kann man auch mal sehen. Die andere Seite, jeder, der mal irgendwie ein bisschen weiter über den Programmiersprachen Tellerrand geguckt hat, der ist natürlich schwer enttäuscht von der Programmiersprache von wie Java, weil unglaubliche Essentials lange gefehlt haben. Es gibt keine anonymen Funktionen, es gab Ewigkeiten, nicht sowas wie Generics oder Templates. Ich weiß nicht, man kann da noch beliebig weitere Dinge aufzählen. Es gab ja noch nicht mal vernünftige Inams bis, ich glaube, Java 1.4 oder wann wurden die?
Ich glaube, mit Generics wurden die Inams eingeführt.
Es fehlt halt auch unglaublich viel. Was sie so nach und nach immer ein bisschen nachgebessert haben, die anonymen Funktionen kann man mittlerweile ja annähern mit den sogenannten anonymen inneren Klassen, aber das ist auch alles andere als eleganter Syntax. Also man bricht sich da so ein bisschen die Finger bei, aber man kann das halt tun, ab und zu braucht man das auch einfach. Es ist halt so ein Least Common Denominator vielleicht, wenn man von C++ traumatisiert war, aber wenn man halt ein bisschen mehr schon gesehen hat, dann kann man auch ganz schön leiden, wenn man den Java programmiert.
Haut dich nicht um, sagst du.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also die Syntax ist auf jeden Fall sehr verbus. Man muss teilweise sehr viel Boilerplate-Code schreiben, um einfachste Sachen wie zum Beispiel einen Array abzulaufen oder also Sachen, die in anderen Programmiersprachen sehr viel bequemer gehen, sind in Java mitunter mit sehr viel Schreiben verbunden. Und das macht es natürlich auch nicht wartbarer. Aber eigentlich...
Hast du nicht vorhin gesagt, Java ist das neue Kobol?
Ja, es ist halt die Enterprise-Sprache.
Weil Kobol wurde ja nun auch mal schon vorgeworfen, dass man da viel schreiben muss.
Ach so, na dann passt das ja. Ich kenne Kobol überhaupt nicht.
Ja, das ist mehr so English-Language eigentlich, so unser Syntax-Erscheinung.
Also ich finde Java gut.
Da braucht man dann immer so eine Typistin irgendwie.
Das sollten Manager lesen können, das war die Idee.
Insofern, als dass es einfach ist. Und man kann aber schon auch komplexe Programme damit schreiben. Also es ist nicht so, dass... Also gerade dieses Multithreading kann einem ganz schön Kopfschmerzen bereiten. Und was halt noch ein Vorteil ist, bei dieser statischen Typisierung, ist halt, dass man guten IDE-Support dafür haben kann. Und auch guten Refactoring-Support. Also die modernen IDEs wie Eclipse, IntelliJ oder auch NetBeans, die haben halt alle sehr viele Refactoring, die man machen kann, automatisiert.
Kannst du das mal ein bisschen erläutern? Also IDE, wir reden von Entwicklungsprogrammierumgebung.
Genau, Editor, Compiler, was gehört noch dazu? Debugger, alles in einem. Syntax-Highlighting, Vervollständigung von Methodennamen, das geht halt mit so einer statisch typisierten Sprache ganz gut, weil schon die IDE weiß, was das Objekt da für Funktionen haben kann oder Methoden haben kann und mir dann auch nur die vorschlägt, die es tatsächlich gibt und auch schon am Rückgabewert erkennen kann, welche Methode, also theoretisch jedenfalls, die das wirklich schon machen, am Rückgabewert schon sehen kann, welche Methode da überhaupt noch in Frage kommt und solche Sachen. Und Refactoring ist halt der Umbauen des Codes, sodass das Design besser wird, kurz gesagt. Also Standard-Sachen wie Extract Method und Introduce Variable und solche Sachen.
Das ist ja auch ganz schön interessant, was da eigentlich passiert ist. Nämlich durch die Schwachstellen der Sprache und auch vielleicht der Umgebung. Nämlich solche Dinge wie die schiere Größe des JDKs. Niemand kann dieses ganze API im Kopf behalten. Das kann man einfach mal knicken. Wo das halt nötig ist, diesen Tool-Support zu entwickeln. Ich glaube, es gibt eigentlich keine weitere Sprache, für die das in dem Maße passiert ist und sich also entwickelt hat wie für Java. Es gibt mindestens drei große IDEs, was jeweils sehr hochkomplexe Stücke Software sind im Prinzip. Eclipse, NetBeans, IntelliJ vielleicht auch noch. Und diese ganzen Refactoring-Geschichten, die dann eben nötig waren, weil man einfach unglaublich große Code-Basen hat, die, wenn man sie bearbeiten möchte und wenn man das von Hand tun muss, dann ist das halt ein sehr unhandlicher Prozess. Also hat man halt den Tool-Support entwickelt. Und das ist schon eine sehr einzigartige Geschichte an Java.
Was heißt, man hat den Tool-Support entwickelt? Also war da jetzt irgendwie... Also hat Sun da jetzt irgendwas betrieben oder hat sich das aus der Community herausentwickelt? Was meinst du jetzt?
Sun kam sogar relativ spät. Eclipse war, glaube ich, die erste große IDE für... Und J-Builder, der war auch schon richtig gut. Also der hat mich davon überzeugt, tatsächlich eine IDE zu verwenden. Bis zum J-Builder 2006 habe ich meinen VI benutzt, um Java-Code zu schreiben, aber...
Was sind denn das jetzt alles für... Also J-Builder ist von Sun?
Nee, nee, J-Builder ist von Borland, gibt es aber nicht mehr. Ist jetzt als Eclipse-Plugin aufgegangen, glaube ich. Heißt jetzt Code-Bier, kann das sein?
Ich habe das aufgehört zu verfolgen.
Das sehe ich mir auch nicht sicher.
Eclipse scheint mir eine der populäreren Umgebungen zu sein für Java.
Was halt daran liegt, dass sie frei ist zunächst mal. Dass IBM da unglaubliche Mengen an Geld auch reingepumpt hat in die Entwicklung, das glaube ich auch nach wie vor tut. Da sieht man vielleicht auch, dass eben die Leute, die halt die wirklich großen Code-Besen haben, nämlich im Enterprise-Bereich, die hatten halt auch erst mit die Notwendigkeit, eine entsprechende IDE zu bauen, sich ein entsprechendes Toolkit zu bauen, um eben schneller ihre Projekte durchziehen zu können. Das kann man da vielleicht auch ganz gut sehen.
Aber ihr verwendet das beide nicht?
Ich bin mit Eclipse nicht warm geworden. Ich bin auch mit dem Emacs nicht warm geworden.
Das wusste ich auch nicht, woran es liegt. Ich bin auch mit Emacs nicht warm geworden, aber wie auch immer.
Erst gab es ihn nicht mehr für einen Mac, genau. Dann habe ich aufgehört, J-Builder zu benutzen. Dann habe ich NetBeans benutzt.
Das ist von Sun?
Das ist von Sun, aber auch Open Source. Aber wird nur von Sun entwickelt. Soweit ich das im Überblick habe, entwickelt dann nur Sun dran. Aber man kann es sich halt auschecken und kompilieren und dann benutzen oder auch runterladen, das Binary. Und NetBeans hat seit der Version 5 ganz schön zugelegt. Davor fand ich es nicht so attraktiv, aber mit der Version 5, also die jetzt auch schon zwei Jahre alt ist, dann ging es los. Und dann kam IntelliJ auf meinen Radar, und zwar deshalb, weil die halt Groovy-Support, und das lenkt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen ab, aber Groovy ist eine andere Programmiersprache für die JVM. Und IntelliJ hat auch immer noch den besten Groovy-Support. Und deshalb habe ich mir IntelliJ IDEA nochmal angeschaut und dann sogar gekauft, weil das muss man kaufen. Das ist die einzig mir bekannte kaufbare IDE, die sich noch...
Was zahlt man dafür?
250 Dollar.
Einmalig.
Einmalig. Dafür eine Version aber nur.
Da muss es ja schon gut sein. Aber liegt das jetzt nur daran, dass auch Groovy unterstützt wird? Oder ist das Ding ansonsten auch gut?
Das ist ansonsten auch gut. Also es hat auch guten Maven-Support und guten... Ach so, Maven, genau. Maven ist halt so ein Build-Tool für Java. Ein sehr komplexes... Jetzt kommen wir vom hundertsten ins tausendste.
Ja, wir sind bei Entwicklungswerkzeugen.
Da gehört Maven definitiv dazu. Also Maven übernimmt für einen unter anderem auch das Dependency-Management. Also in Java programmiert man nicht so sehr, wie ich das in C erlebt habe, alles selber und fängt immer wieder bei Null an, sondern man hat ganz viele Libraries. Man hat für Mail eine Library, für IMAP, für Surflits, für alles gibt es im Grunde schon. Für RSS-Pausen gibt es Libraries, und dann gibt es natürlich von jeder dieser Libraries noch verschiedene Versionen. Und Maven ermöglicht das einem, und die hängen auch noch untereinander voneinander ab. Also da gibt es dann transitive Abhängigkeiten. Das heißt, wenn ich eine bestimmte Library verwende, dann braucht die wieder eine andere, und die braucht wieder eine andere und so weiter, bis man dann die letzte Library auch noch included hat. Und Maven, da gibt man eine Dependency ins Konfigurationsfile rein, und dann holt sich Maven den ganzen Kram aus dem Repository, entweder aus dem eigenen Repository von der Firma, und tut sie ins lokale Repository auf dem Rechner oder eben von dem globalen Repository. Und Maven macht noch mehr. Es gibt Lifecycle-Phasen, also Kompilieren des Source Codes, packetieren, Tests ausführen, also Unit-Tests oder auch Integration-Tests, Code-Analyse, Statische-Analyse des Codes, Java-Docs generieren. Also Maven deckt quasi den gesamten Prozess von ich check den Source Code aus bis ich habe einen Programm, was ich direkt laufen lassen kann auf meinem Rechner plus alle. Dann gibt es noch Maven-Side-Reports, dass man noch eine Webseite zu dem Programm gleich dazu hat. Also Maven deckt den kompletten Bildprozess ab.
Man will nicht ohne.
Na doch, viele Leute wollen ohne. Aber es hat auch seine Nachteile.
Der Haken an Maven ist, dass es eine gewisse Lernkurve hat, bis man reinkommt, weil man das ganze Modell verstehen muss. Wenn man gewachsene Strukturen hat oder einen außergewöhnlichen Bildprozess, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, hat man unter Umständen damit zu kämpfen, das mit Maven zusammenzuschweißen.
Man hat auch ein grundsätzliches Problem, wenn man kurz keine Netzwerkverbindung hat. Maven schaut jedes Mal, ob sich die Dependencies geändert haben, ob man eine neue Version von dem Java braucht. Das holt die dann auch einfach.
Guckt wo? Guckt im Internet?
Genau.
Wo guckt es da?
Auf dem definierten Repository. Da kann auch mal was hinkommen, was man nicht auf der Platte haben will.
Gibt es da genau eins? Gibt es für Maven eine Server-Infrastruktur, wo er nachschaut, oder muss man das selber vorhalten?
Es gibt ein globales, aber man kann auch weitere globale definieren. Eigentlich will man aber, wenn man unternehmenskritische Sachen damit macht, ein Proxy haben und jemanden, der diesen Proxy auch wartet und aufpasst, dass, wenn eine neue Version geholt wird, dass er die schon mal ausprobiert hat. Weil es kann auch sein, du machst einen App. Bei Maven kann man auch angeben, diese Version oder höher. Und selbst wenn man nur diese Version angibt, kann trotzdem jemand auf dem Repository die Version ausgetauscht haben gegen ein anderes Binary, was zwar dieselbe Version hat, aber trotzdem anders ist. Und dann funktioniert plötzlich gar nichts mehr. Oder es tut was Böses. Oder was Böses, genau. Man muss ja schon aufpassen.
Maven gehört ja zum Apache-Projekt. Apache hat überhaupt eine ganze Menge Java-Zeug. Das ist eine lange Liste. Da könnte man vielleicht auch noch mal drauf eingehen. Aber jetzt im Zusammenhang mit Bildtools kenne ich nur Ant, was auch schon in Java geschrieben war. Und auch so als Bildtools.
Wie steht das zu Make? Ant ist sozusagen wie Make. Es ist auch so entwickelt worden. Man brauchte etwas, was für Java geht. Und platformübergreifend funktionierte Make war es halt nicht. Und das ist Ant. Und Ant ist im Grunde halt wie Make nur für Java. Das heißt, man kann sich mit Ant in einem Bildprozess zusammenschustern. Aber man muss halt alles selber schreiben. Und man muss vor allen Dingen auch diese Libraries, da muss man sich überlegen, tue ich die in mein SVN mit rein, damit sich jeder Entwickler hat, wenn er das Projekt auscheckt. Oder muss jeder Entwickler sich eine Liste von Libraries abarbeiten, die er sich erstmal runterlädt und in sein Lipsverzeichnis tut. Oder macht Ant das vielleicht, dass es die Sachen runterlädt. Also es macht nicht das Dependency-Management. Ant an sich. Da gibt es noch Ivy, glaube ich, was das macht, aber das kenne ich auch nicht so gut. Also Ant, mit Ant kann man sich einen Bildprozess zusammenbauen. Aber mit Maven hat man ihn halt gleich und muss ihn nur noch konfigurieren. So würde ich sagen, ist der Zusammenhang zwischen Ant und Maven. Also wenn man erstmal Maven drauf hat, dann will man Ant nicht mehr benutzen, sage ich jetzt mal so.
Ja, das kann man schon ungefähr so sagen. Es sei denn, man hat wirklich sehr außergewöhnliche Strukturen oder so. Oder man hat vielleicht auch Teile seines Projekts in Ant einfach schon da und will das nicht umstellen.
Aber das, man kann ja in Maven auch Ant integrieren. Also man kann in Maven auch Ant-Aufrufe machen. Und es gibt natürlich auch Plugins für Maven für jeden Kram.
Aber ich muss gestehen, ganz oft mache ich mir überhaupt nicht die Mühe, eins von den beiden Bildhut zu benutzen. Ich setze die Projekte einfach in der IDE auf. Und das reicht für viele kleine Sachen auch völlig aus.
Ich mache inzwischen alles mit Maven. Also auch die kleinste Sache, weil ich will auch die IDE wechseln können und will dann nicht von vorne anfangen müssen oder dann noch irgendwas. Also mit Maven kann man wirklich auschecken. Maven, irgendwie install, und dann ist es fertig. Oder man kann auch direkt mit Jetty run gleich in einen Web-Server starten, ja, in einen Web-Server, dann in einen Server-Container mit starten, und dann läuft die Applikation gleich da drin und man kann sie gleich lokal ausprobieren. Wobei, mit Arnd hat man das auch schon, diese Plattform. Also wenn man NetBeans zum Beispiel verwendet, das verwendet der standardmäßig Arnd. Und da kommen dann auch Projekte bei raus, die kann man runterladen, mit Arnd bauen und hat dann auch hinterher was. Ja.
Was für, also ist das dann auch schon alles, was man braucht? Also wenn man jetzt einen Java entwickeln will, dann entscheidet man sich für eine dieser Ideen im Idealfall. Also man braucht es natürlich nicht unbedingt. Man kann es hier auf der Kommando-Zeile so loslegen, aber ich denke, wir stimmen alle überein, dass so eine Idee schon eine sinnvolle Sache ist. Wie auch umfangreich sie dann auch mal sein mag. Einfach auch ein bisschen Überblick zu erhalten. Das heißt, man könnte jetzt irgendwas nehmen. Gibt es dann sonst noch irgendwelche wertvollen Werkzeuge, die man sich im Einsatz hat, die sinnvoll sind?
Also es gibt schon noch ein paar Tools, aber das kommt man dann schnell in den kommerziellen Bereich, wo man dann auch eine ganze Menge Geld dafür bezahlt. Also es gibt sehr gute Profiling-Tools, kommerzielle J-Profiler, glaube ich, hatte ich mal im Einsatz, womit ich auch ganz zufrieden war, der halt sehr ausgefeilt war.
Der geht dann über das eigene Programm und sagt, wo es viel Zeit verbraucht ist.
Genau, und dann hat man ganz tolle Diagramme und kann das eingrenzen und tausend Möglichkeiten.
Also der Cook sieht das zur Laufzeit an. Weil es gibt nämlich auch noch Analysetools, die über den Sourcecode gehen.
Dann habe ich neulich was Schönes gesehen, wo ich leider vergessen habe, wie das heißt, was ich ganz toll fand für, ich habe eine alte Software und muss die aufräumen. Und zwar war das ein Tool, da konnte man Layers definieren, da konnte man halt sagen, ja, ich möchte meine Software sehr layerorientiert bauen und diese Klassen gehören in dieses Layer und diese Klassen gehören in jenes Layer. Und dann hat einem das sehr schöne Meldung gemacht, gab es als Plugin für diverse IDE's, sehr schöne Meldung gemacht, hier wird deine Layer-Architektur verletzt, hier greift mal Code von dem oberen Layer in das untere Layer, das sollte doch eigentlich alles gar nicht so sein. Und hat einem also dabei unterstützt, entweder von vornherein so zu entwickeln, aber eben auch alte Software aufzuräumen, die halt mit entsprechenden Schwachstellen ausgestattet ist. Das fand ich auch sehr schön, hat mir gefallen, als ich das gesehen habe. Und dann natürlich gibt es sicherlich noch eine Menge Dinge, habe ich noch nicht so viel mit gearbeitet im kommerziellen Umfeld, so hinsichtlich mit UML-Arbeiten und mit diesen ganzen formalen Entwicklungsprozessen arbeiten. Und da gibt es auch nochmal eine ganze Menge Zeug, das man für viel Geld kaufen und benutzen kann oder eben auch nicht.
Also bei Java ist vor allem immer wieder Beeindruckt, es gibt vor allem viel, oder? Also es gibt wirklich einfach eine erschlagende Anzahl von Werkzeugen und Tools und sonstigen Add-ons für allen möglichen Scheiß. Was halt wirklich auch aus dieser starken Position heraus, glaube ich, kommt, die es jetzt einfach, wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, so im Enterprise-Bereich hat. Also Java ist de facto, glaube ich, die stärkste Programmierumgebung mittlerweile so für Business-Anwendungen im Server-Bereich. Würdet ihr mir da zustimmen?
Ja, würde ich schon so sehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es beurteilen kann, aber es kommt mir auch so vor.
Schön zurückhaltend formuliert, danke. Ja, aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, ich wüsste auch nicht, was, also ich wüsste nicht, was sonst jetzt entspricht, weil dieser hohe Grad an Austauschbarkeit und an Zuverlässigkeit beim Laufen lassen. Also klar, man kann sagen, das läuft jetzt vielleicht nicht so schnell, wie ich will, und auch da kann man gespaltener Meinung sein, oder es hat diese und jeden Einschränkungen. Aber ich denke, was wirklich eine Offenbarung war, das muss ich auch wirklich zugestehen, immerhin hat Sunnys geschafft, ein Problem zu lösen, was die allermeisten Systeme nicht gelöst haben. Und zwar teilweise bis heute noch nicht gelöst haben, nämlich dieses Packaging von Software. Man kann einfach sein Programm in diesen Bytecode überführen. Und dann in diesem, ja, also wird ja durch das richtig, wenn so die Klassen einzeln kompiliert in diese Jar-Archive reingepackt und wenn ich die irgendwie zusammen packe zu einem Programm, dann kann ich das halt einfach deliveren und man kann davon ausgehen, dass es überall läuft.
Also in dem Jar steht schon drin, was die Main-Klasse ist, wo dann auch die Einsprung-Methode sozusagen ist. Also so ein Jar ist tatsächlich, kann man sagen, ausführbar, wenn man es entspricht. Also mit Java minus Jar, Jar-Name, kann man tatsächlich das Programm starten.
Ja, es geht zum Laufen, es war vollkommen egal, ob das ein Computer. Das ist ja schon mal was wert.
Wenn das JRE installiert ist, ja.
Ja klar, natürlich. Aber auch das ist ja nun meistens gegeben, davon gehe ich jetzt einfach mal aus. Aber es ist halt nicht so, dass man auf der einen Plattform noch irgendwie diesen und jenen Klimmzug machen muss, um diesen Code auszuführen, sondern er läuft halt. Er läuft vielleicht nicht optimal oder super megaschnell, aber ein Programm, was überhaupt läuft, ist ja schon mal eine ganze Menge wert.
Für Mac OS und für Windows gibt es halt auch so einen Excel- und App-Wrapper. Man sieht den Programm dann gar nicht an, dass es ein Java-Programm ist, weil es hat halt einen App-Ordner.
Aber es setzt trotzdem voraus, dass das Java installiert ist.
Man kann sogar die JRE mit reinpacken. Also unter Windows ist das gar nicht so unüblich, habe ich mir sagen lassen sie das JRE, weil da hat man gleich immer das Richtige dabei und da tut man die 13 MB dann halt noch mit rein.
Mehr ist das nicht?
Also Java 5 war glaube ich 13 MB.
Das nimmt sich heute gar nicht mehr so groß aus bei den typischen Installationsgrößen.
Es sind halt keine 20. Ketten mehr.
Und damals war es ja auch noch keine.
Gut. Wir haben es ja schon ein bisschen angerissen. Bevor wir jetzt auf andere Bereiche kommen. Es gibt ja nicht nur diese Implementierung von Sun. Es gibt ja, also ich meine Sun, Java war jetzt jahrelang ein kommerzielles Produkt. Und obwohl es große Erfolge hatte im Open Source Bereich im Sinne von, dass sehr viel Open Source Software in Java geschrieben worden ist, war die Laufzeit selber halt irgendwie komisch. War halt irgendwie nicht frei, konnte nicht beliebig kopiert werden und so weiter. Und das führte dann zu zwei Effekten. Das eine hatten wir schon gesagt, so es hat viele Leute vom Kopf gestoßen, bzw. sie haben einfach nicht begriffen, wie sie es zum Laufen kriegen, weil sie auf der Webseite nicht klarkamen. Aber vor allem denke ich mal, als eben viele andere Entwickler eingeschränkt, die gesagt haben, ok Java hat ja an sich eine ganze Menge Promise, aber wenn es unter der Lizenz kommt, wie jetzt, dann brauchen wir eine Alternative dazu. Und das hat ja dazu geführt, dass es auch zahlreiche alternative Implementierungen gegeben hat und immer noch gibt. Welche sind da so die wichtigsten, die jetzt noch eine Rolle spielen?
Die von IBM.
Die von IBM auf jeden Fall.
Und dann BEA, WebSphere. Ich weiß gar nicht, die von IBM. Ja, wie hieß die? Blackdown?
Die hatte so einen typischen Projekt-Codename, aber nicht wirklich. Das ist einfach das JIA von IBM. Das verstehen Leute, wenn man davon spricht.
Und JROCKET gibt es auch noch. Die sind allerdings noch bei Java 5, glaube ich. Also im Grunde hat Sun alle anderen abgehängt, würde ich mal so behaupten.
Aber es gibt dann noch dieses Apache-Harmony-Projekt.
Das ist eine Reimplementation der Standard-Library. Dann gibt es dieses Cafe-JVM. Die hatten sich, glaube ich, mal auf Embedded spezialisiert, wenn ich mich da richtig entsinne. Und dann denke ich, es gibt auch noch eine ganze Menge Sachen im akademischen Umfeld, weil was halt auch passiert ist, dass die Java-Platform quasi gesehen wurde oder vor allen Dingen die JVM als Experimentierfeld für Compiler-Optimierung und dergleichen. Da ist auch einiges passiert. Ich glaube, da ist auch mit Cafe einiges passiert, dass Leute da irgendwelche speziellen Sachen für implementiert haben und geguckt haben, was das bringt und so weiter. Aber das ist vielleicht für den kommerziellen Einsatz oder auch für den richtigen Anwendungseinsatz nicht so relevant, diese Geschichten.
Also ich kann mich nur erinnern, dass zur Zeiten von 1.3 Java war die IBM Virtual Machine einfach schneller als die von Sun. Aber später hat Sun dann aufgeholt.
Ja, aber heute ist Java GPL.
Es dauert noch ein paar Tage, bis es vollständig ist. Da fehlte noch bei meinem letzten Vortrag, den ich gehört habe, da fehlte noch irgendwas. Und es wird aber absehbar, dass es vollständig GPL ist.
Okay, das heißt, lizenzmäßig geht es sozusagen auf den Level, auf dem dich Linux befindet. Es ist alles GPL-lizenziert, von daher halt frei. Allerdings ist da glaube ich auch nicht jeder mit glücklich. Also das Apache-Projekt hat sich da glaube ich schon auch mehrfach beschwert.
Na gut, letztlich sind die ja auch mit der gar nicht freien Lizenz klargekommen. Also die werden jetzt auch mit der GPL klar kommen, weil es da ja keine Binärabhängigkeiten oder... Also man kann trotzdem noch Apache-Lizenz-Projekte auch mit dem GPL JDK vermischen. Also ich glaube, da wird es auch weiterhin keine Probleme geben.
Auch wenn das über diese Apis... Also ich meine, wie ist denn das? Also die ganzen, ja wie nennt man das? Diese ganzen Kids von Sun, die ganzen Libraries oder Classes, wie nennt man denn das? Frameworks?
Frameworks würde man das Apple wahrscheinlich nennen, ja.
Libraries kann man das verinneren.
Libraries ist schon gut.
So, die sind dann ja auch sozusagen unter GPL. Und was ist das? Man linkt ja sozusagen dein Programm ja eigentlich nicht wirklich dazu.
Genau, deshalb gibt es auch da keine Probleme. Man benutzt halt die API und das war bisher in Ordnung und das wird auch in Zukunft in Ordnung sein. Also es besteht glaube ich nicht die Gefahr, dass wenn irgendwer die...
Linkt man überhaupt noch irgendwas unter Java?
Nicht mal wenn man nach C-Called linkt man.
Ja, man hat da halt in dem Class-File steht halt so ein Stream drin und das ist quasi der Package-Pfad zu der Klasse und dann die Methode und dann noch die Parameter und die wird dann auf grün... Weiß nicht, ob man das Linken nennt.
Naja, es ist so halt so ein dynamisches Dazuladen von Bibliotheken, so. Also da kann man jetzt eine esoterische Diskussion mit starten. Also ihr seht da auf jeden Fall kein Problem mit der Lizenz-Geschichte.
Ich bin halt keine Lizenz-Experte, aber ich denke, das ist kein klassisches statisches Linken auf keinen Fall.
Gut, Tatsache ist, es gibt verschiedene Implementierungen. Ich habe diese Apache-Harmony jetzt auch nochmal hervorgehoben, weil dazu ja auch dieses, also die eigentliche Randheim, die da drunter ist, ist dieses, wie heißt es, Dalvik. Und das ist ja jetzt von Google verwendet worden als Basis ihres Android-Projektes. Das heißt, Google setzt bei Android tatsächlich auf Java, die Programmiersprache.
Dürfen sie es aber nicht so nennen?
Dürfen sie es noch nicht mal so nennen?
Nee, sie dürfen es nicht Java nennen, soweit ich weiß.
Weil?
Weil sie nicht, weil das nicht TCK zertifiziert ist, irgendwie Test Compatibility Kit. Also dieses Dalvik ist keine Java-VM.
Okay, aber es ist eine Java-VM. Und die Programmiersprache, diese Verwendung ist auch Java.
Es fehlen aber auch Sachen. Es fehlen auch dieser Dalvik-VM. Es fehlen auch Dinge, die die Java-VM hat.
Jetzt im Sinne von, dass es schneller und besser ist? Oder wirklich, es fehlt ein Feature, das bestimmter Code nicht ausgeführt werden könnte?
Ich habe es jetzt leider nicht auf dem Kasten, aber es gibt zum Beispiel kein Groovy für Android, weil Groovy-Features der Virtual Machine verwendet, die einfach Dalvik nicht hat.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir doch nochmal erklären, was Groovy ist, weil du das jetzt schon zweimal erwähnt hast.
Groovy ist eine Programmiersprache für die Java-VM, die sehr stark, also seit ich mir jetzt Ruby ein bisschen genauer angeguckt habe, kommt es mir so vor, als wenn es einfach sehr stark an Ruby angelehnt ist. Und räumt halt so ein bisschen mit dieser verbosen Syntax auf. Also man kann da sehr viel, sehr kompakt darstellen. Es ist außerdem dynamisch typisiert bzw. kann beides sein. Man kann statisch typisieren oder dynamisch typisieren in Groovy.
Also man kann es verwenden, um Java auch zu skripten?
Man kann, also es integriert sich sehr gut mit Java. Weil man kann z.B. von Java-Klassen Groovy-Klassen ableiten und man kann dann auch von diesen Groovy-Klassen wieder Java-Klassen ableiten. Also in dem Objektmodell ist es voll drin. Und von der Syntax her, man kann auch in Groovy-Klassen fast Java-Code schreiben. Da gibt es noch ganz wenige Ausnahmen. Ares initialisieren geht nicht gleich. Also man kann nicht gleich schreiben, irgendwie String. Also man kann...
Aber es ist halt eine dynamische Pro-Misprache im Gegensatz zu Java.
Genau, dynamisch typisiert und auch dynamisch.
Hat mehr von Python, hat mehr von Ruby oder Pearl als es jetzt von C hat. Und läuft aber in derselben VM. Und man kann es auch dazu verwenden, um einen anderen Java-Code zu benutzen und aufzurufen. Das ist ja das, was man Skripting nennt. Man hat eine dynamische Sprache und die benutzt einen anderen Code, der schon da ist. Groovy ist eigentlich das, was man hätte Java-Skript nennen müssen.
Ja, das kann man so sehen.
Aber leider hieß Java-Skript schon Java-Skript, obwohl es eigentlich mal Live-Skript hieß und nicht Java ist und Java-Skript auch nicht in der Java-VM läuft.
Also Groovy kompiliert vor allen Dingen halt in Class-Files. Das heißt, sobald es kompiliert ist, fühlt es sich an wie Java. Also es wird Bytecode generiert und der läuft halt auch in der Java-Virtual-Maschine.
Das heißt, Groovy ist eigentlich eine vollwertige Programmiersprachen-Alternative, die sich vollständig in derselben Plattform bewegt wie Java auch. Man ist da First Class Citizen.
Genau, man kann die sämtliche Java-Appies verwenden und man kann sogar von sämtlichen Java-Appies verwendet werden. Also wenn ich einen Jar generiere mit Class Files, die aus Groovy-Sourcecode entstanden sind, dann kann ich das irgendwo hin, in irgendeinem Java-Programm vorwerfen und das kann diese Library verwenden, als wäre es in Java geschrieben.
Wie populär ist Groovy?
Das geht gerade los. Seit ein, zwei Jahren. Seit zwei Jahren geht es los mit Groovy. Also bei uns in der Firma wird auch Groovy schon in mehreren Projekten eingesetzt. Momentan hauptsächlich noch in Verbindung mit Grails. Also Grails ist sozusagen das Rails für Groovy. Sie hatten es glaube ich sogar zuerst als Groovy on Rails genannt, aber das wurde ihnen dann quasi verboten. Aber sie haben gesagt, nenn es mal lieber nicht Rails, sondern nenn es mal irgendwie anders.
Groovy on Rails sozusagen.
Genau, dann haben sie es Grails genannt. Das ist halt ein Web-Framework, mit dem man wie in Ruby on Rails sehr schnell einfache und auch komplexere Web-Applikationen entwickeln kann.
Das klingt ja eigentlich ganz pfiffig. Also ich meine, wenn man da den Vorteil hat, alle Ressourcen zu nutzen, die Java bietet, aber diesen Nachteil der statischen Programmiersprache nicht mehr hat.
Also ich finde es total pfiffig und was ein bisschen verwunderlich ist, ist, dass Sun eher JRuby gepusht hat. Sun hat die zwei Entwickler von JRuby quasi angestellt und damit sie weiter JRuby machen. Also JRuby ist sozusagen das Ruby für die Virtual Machine und hat halt nicht so sehr auf Groovy gesetzt. Wobei, man muss es vielleicht verstehen, Ruby war halt sehr viel populärer zu dem Zeitpunkt und Groovy ist ja auch so gewachsen ohne das Thunder, was dafür tut. Insofern haben wir jetzt halt beides, Groovy und JRuby. Und dann gibt es noch Jython und das ist halt Python für die Java Virtual Machine. Und dann gibt es noch Scala. Das ist eine funktionale Programmiersprache, die auch statisch typisiert ist und mit der ich noch nichts gemacht habe, aber wo ich so ein bisschen die Vorstellung habe, dass sie so ein bisschen das Erlang für die JVM werden könnte. Also da gibt es halt auch Actors nennt sich das Konzept. Das sind halt leichtgewichtige Threads, die ja eher lang sehr populär gemacht haben. Und ja, das ist alles sehr, sehr, sehr interessant, was es da an Sprachen gibt.
Scala hat auch noch ein paar andere Vorteile. Scala hat zum Beispiel ein sehr schönes Konzept für Mehrfachvererbung, unter dem Namen Threads formiert und hat auch eine wesentlich bessere Lösung für Generics. Also das ist eine ganz interessante Sprache, die auch sicherlich einige Aufmerksamkeit im Moment hat. Von Groovy selber kann ich nur sagen, dass ich damit nie so richtig warm geworden bin. Ich habe mir das irgendwie zwei, drei Mal angeguckt und was mich immer genervte, dass die Fehlermeldungen vom Compiler waren, die waren wesentlich zu uninformativ. Also ich habe da immer Ewigkeiten gerätselt, was er mir denn nur eigentlich sagen wollte, was an meinem Code nicht gepasst hat.
Ja, und was richtig genervt ist, dass die meisten Fehler halt erst zur Laufzeit auftreten, weil es halt so eine dynamische Sprache ist. Das heißt, der Compiler kann gar nicht wissen, was dieses Objekt für Methoden hat, weil zur Laufzeit kann da noch jemand Methoden rangeklatscht haben und dann hat es die Methoden halt. Genau, das ist halt die große Freiheit und dann muss man halt viele Tests haben, damit man das in den Tests schon mitkriegt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant zu sehen, dass jetzt die Java-VM als solche sozusagen auch Heimat wird für andere Sprachprojekte. Also sowohl bestehende Sprachen. Wir hatten jetzt Ruby, Python und habe auch gerade gesehen, es gibt auch eine JavaScript-Implementierung für Java-VM mit Rhino und Scala als neue Sprache. Es gibt sogar einen Common Lisp, was irgendwie in der Java-VM läuft.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist noch nicht der Schluss.
Ja gut, das ist sicherlich alles. Aber Sie sehen, Java-VM ist irgendwie deployed. Die gibt es irgendwie. Und wenn man es schafft, da ein Good Citizen zu sein, innerhalb der VM, dann hat man quasi kostenlos Plattform-Support.
Das ist insbesondere dann cool, wenn man in der Firma ist, die Java als Plattform-only ist, fast.
Aber kein Bock, Java zu programmieren.
Nein, man kann dann halt so ein bisschen durch die kalte Küche ein paar andere Sprachen reinbringen, die nicht gleich abgelehnt wird. Genau, man kann das Zeug dann trotzdem in derselben Struktur deployen. Da gibt es eine Tomcat-Farm und da kann dann das VAR draufgeschmissen werden. Also Scala, da kommt auch ein VAR hinten raus. Die haben nicht nur Bytecode, den sie erzeugen, der kompatibel ist.
VAR war dieser Content?
Web Archive, genau. Sondern die Abstraktion geht noch höher, sodass man auch in den Containern läuft. Also es gibt ja auch EJB-Container und...
Was war das nochmal?
Enterprise Java Beans, da bin ich zum Beispiel nie richtig warm geworden. Spring ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Container.
Ach so, Beans, muss man sagen, das ist glaube ich das Komponentensystem, wo man sozusagen...
Also Beans an sich ist eigentlich nur eine Vereinbarung, dass es Getter und Setter gibt. Und die Enterprise Beans, die haben halt noch viel mehr. Da gibt es halt Managed Beans, aber da weißt du wahrscheinlich mehr drüber.
Ja, das ist halt so eine übliche Namensverwurstelung. Eigentlich gibt es halt mindestens zwei Komponentenmodelle, mal davon, was es da noch sonst an Wildwuchs in der freien Wildbahn gibt. Es gibt halt die klassischen Java Beans, wo es halt, wie du sagst, darum geht, dass man Getter und Setter hat und wohl definierte Properties und man kann halt zur Randheim so eine Klasse oder so ein Objekt fragen, welche Properties hast du denn und wie kann ich die denn bearbeiten und alles sowas. Und dann gibt es halt dazu noch, man hat sich an diesen Namen angelehnt, als man mal damals irgendwie mit den AGBs angefangen hat, und da geht es dann um ganz andere Geschichten. Da geht es dann um Dinge wie Transaktionssupport plötzlich und verteilte Ausführungen. Also da kommen noch tausende andere Geschichten dazu und das muss man schon so ein bisschen als so einen separaten Schnatz, kann man schon sagen, muss man das schon noch mal sehen. Ja, wegen den Sprachen, was ich da noch sagen wollte, im Prinzip, was du sagst, du kannst halt die JVM nehmen und dann da halt deine, die eigene Sprache reinbringen, sei es nur Groovy oder vielleicht sogar Lisp oder was auch immer. Da sieht man halt den Vorteil von Java ist halt dieses Ökosystem, das es darum gibt. Ja, ich bekomme halt Server-Hosting dafür und auch an anderer Stelle, Sun hat das halt immer wieder geschafft, so kleine Nischen zu schaffen. Ja, also man sagt halt, man hat halt ein Problem identifiziert, mal wegen wie AGB oder wie Web-Servelets oder wie im Enterprise-Bereich, wo ich mehr auch war, Message-Queuing-Systeme. Ja, dann hat man halt eine API definiert und dann konnten das immer 15 verschiedene Hersteller implementieren. Und dann hat man da so ein bisschen Konkurrenz zugelassen, aber dadurch, dass es ein einheitliches API gibt, gab es eine gewisse Neutralität für wer auch immer so ein System nutzen wollte, hat halt auf die Hersteller unabhängige Schnittstelle aufgesetzt und hatte dann auch eine gewisse Auswahl in den Produkten. Und mit dieser Strategie haben sie halt dieses sehr sehr lebendige Ökosystem geschaffen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch mal ein Punkt, der erwähnenswert ist.
Ja, es gibt für Java-Persistence-API gibt es halt eine API, um Sachen zu persistieren. Oder für JDBC gibt es halt eine Schnittstelle, um auf SQL-Datenbanken zuzugreifen. Und für jedes größere Problem gibt es eine API. Und dann gibt es diverse Implementierungen, kommerzielle Implementierungen oder auch Open Source-Implementierungen. Und da ist man dann nicht festgelegt. Also man kann erstmal, man programmiert gegen diese API, benutzt dann irgendwas und wenn man merkt, oh, MySQL ist doch nicht das, was ich brauche, dann nehme ich halt Oracle und dann schmeißt man halt einen anderen JDBC-Adapter dahin und dann kann man Oracle nehmen. Und dann geht es vielleicht besser oder schlechter oder anders.
Und hast du das Gefühl, dass diese Kapselung manchmal auch ein Hindernis ist? Weil natürlich jede Abstraktion schränkt ja sozusagen auch die potenziellen Features ein.
Da ist halt auch der Kampf immer natürlich, die Hersteller versuchen irgendwelche Alleinstellungsmerkmale zu bieten, die halt über das API dann hinausgehen. Dass man halt dann nur mit ihrem Produkt machen kann und das API muss dann wieder ein bisschen nachreifen. Das ist so, da ist ein gewisser Kampf, der da stattfindet. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es doch trotzdem im Laufe der Zeit reifen diese APIs halt und werden relativ mature. Ja, JDBC, ich weiß nicht in welcher Version ist das jetzt mittlerweile. Genau. Aus Sicht des Nutzers dieser Schnittstellen ist das im Großen und Ganzen, würde ich den Prozess schon positiv bewerten. Weil ich halt doch eine klare Schnittstelle habe, auf die ich mich halbwegs verlassen kann. Klar gibt es da immer mal Ausrutscher und das wird nicht immer 100% sauber implementiert, aber im Großen und Ganzen haut das schon hin.
Wer macht denn diesen Prozess? Also ich meine bisher war alles Sun, aber wenn das jetzt GPL ist, wie läuft denn jetzt, wer ist denn jetzt der tonangebende Faktor? Wie einigt man sich denn da?
Es war bisher schon nicht nur Sun. Also soweit ich das verstanden habe, sind all diese APs im JCP-Prozess. Also das war schon ein Prozess zu viel. JCP heißt schon Java Community Process. Da sitzen mindestens drei Leute drin. Und einer ist von Sun in der Regel, einer beispielsweise von IBM und der Dritte dann vielleicht von Google. Also Sun hat immer nur eine Stimme von mehreren und kann auch überstimmt werden in diesem Prozess. Und in diesem Prozess werden die JSRs entwickelt, die Java Specification Requests. Und die sind dann sozusagen die RFCs für Java. Und das ist dann das Dokument an, das sich dann möglichst alle halten. Und klar gibt es da auch Fides. Also zum Beispiel OSGI hat es lange schwer, mit ihrem Packaging JSR irgendwie durchzukommen. Das sind sie jetzt aber, glaube ich. Und gleichzeitig hat Sun aber noch eine eigene Spezifikation für Packaging gemacht. Also du meintest ja vorhin, dass das mit den Jars schon eine feine Sache wäre. Aber im Grunde ist das eben noch nicht so die feine Sache, weil man doch sehr schnell in der Jar-Hölle landet. Also man hat viele verschiedene, also wenn man so Projekte zusammenführt zu einem Projekt, beispielsweise, dann kommen die mit verschiedenen Abhängigkeiten und manchmal kommen sie aber auch mit derselben Abhängigkeit nur in verschiedenen Versionen. Und dann muss man sich halt entscheiden, welche Version nehme ich denn, oder will ich das verstecken, welche Version ich da gerade brauche. Und OSGi ist halt ein System, wo man zur Laufzeit Abhängigkeiten nachladen kann und auch wieder rauswerfen kann. Und das heißt nicht OSGi, das ist glaube ich das Konsortium.
Also ich habe hier gerade mal nachgeschlagen, das ist jetzt hier auch als JSR, also Java Specification Request Nummer 291 festgehalten und steht hier unter Dynamic Component Support. Also sozusagen eine Meta-Definition für Komponenten, wo dann sozusagen mehr definiert ist als nur Getter Setdown, Triperties, verstehe. Okay, das heißt, okay, sprich Sun hat da einen Community-Prozess aufgesetzt oder den Community-Prozess. Der heißt, wir einigen uns gemeinsam auf, wie die Java-Platform sich weiterentwickelt, damit nicht nur Sun das hier sagen hat, weil klar, dann würde man sich nicht wirklich da einigen können und Sun würde nur das Problem haben, dass eben andere, irgendwelche anderen Wege gehen, die am Ende noch populärer sind und dann ist es nicht mehr einheitlich. Und sie orientieren sich so ein bisschen, kann man sagen, dass sie sich wirklich an diesem RFC-Prozess des Internets da orientieren oder ist das etwas vermessen?
Das ist schon mein Eindruck, dass sie sich daran orientieren.
Ich meine, es würde Sun gut zu Gesicht stellen. Das ist immerhin eine der wenigen Firmen, wo das, ich meine, Sun hat nun wirklich, ich meine, das ist echt ein Laden mit History. Ich meine, Sun hat uns Unix gebracht. Kann man einfach mal de facto mal so kurz festhalten. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob jeder so den Einblick hat, was Sun für so eine Geschichte hat. Aber natürlich ist die Firma stark geworden mit dem Aufkommen von dem BSD-Unix-Prozess. Und Unix war halt lange Zeit einfach das, was auf Sun Workstations lief. Weil das war halt in den Unis, in den USA, das wurde wirklich benutzt. Auch in Deutschland. Da ist TCP-IP groß geworden, da ist das Internet eigentlich groß geworden auf Sun Computern.
NFS und so Dinge.
NFS, RPC haben wir vorhin schon erwähnt. Also viele, viele, viele Standards, die heute unter Unix und im Internet als selbstverständlich angesehen werden, hatten ihre Quelle bei Sun. Sie sind ja auch immer wieder für Überraschung gut. Hier ZFS, das neue Datalsystem, ist ja auch so ein Beispiel. Das ist alles, was aus Sun rauskommt. Insofern muss man auch sagen, es ist schon bemerkenswert, wie gut Sun das auch durchgestanden hat mit dem Java. Ich muss sagen, ich hätte da nicht so damit gerechnet, dass sie sich wirklich so breit machen würden. Aber das ist ihnen ja ganz gut gelungen.
Also das JCP ist ein offener Prozess. Das ist schon so. Bei J2MI zum Beispiel ist Nokia auch noch ganz groß, weil die halt J2MI natürlich ihr Interesse haben. Oder es sind auch andere, ich glaube Samsung. Alle größeren Mobiltelefonhersteller sitzen da auch so ein bisschen mit drin. Und trotzdem, da so viele Firmen drin sitzen, kommt immer noch was bei raus. Also das funktioniert.
Trotzdem kann man nicht gerade sagen, dass jetzt Java-Software auf Mobiltelefonen, also wie viel Verbreitung hat das wirklich?
Na also die JVM für Mobiltelefone hat eine sehr hohe Verbreitung.
Ja gut, sie ist überall installiert. Aber wie groß ist wirklich so die Streuerung von Software? Wie viel Software entsteht wirklich auf Basis von J2MI, die wirklich deployed wird?
Mit Spielen auf J2MI werden schon Milliarden umgesetzt. Andere Software kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber ich fand es schon ganz praktisch, mir meinen RSS-Reader selber schreiben zu können für meinen Mobiltelefon, als ich das mal brauchte, dass der was kann, was die anderen nicht.
Und wie plattformunabhängig war das dann real?
Ich habe ihn nur auf meinem Telefon eingesetzt, aber ich habe ihn schon so programmiert, dass er eigentlich auf vielen Telefonen, die zumindest ein mehrzahliges Display haben, funktionieren müsste.
Ich habe es auch mal ausprobiert, da irgendwas zum Laufen zu kriegen und zumindest so ein Setup überhaupt mehr zum Laufen zu kriegen. Das war dann bei Macintosh-Plattformen irgendwie überhaupt nicht ordentlich unterstützt wurde damals.
Immer noch nicht. Es gibt einen Emulator, Power Player, den benutzen glaube ich alle, die auf dem Mac J2ME entwickeln. Wobei jetzt letztens habe ich noch einen anderen entdeckt, den muss ich noch einmal genauer anschauen.
Was ist denn da eigentlich das Problem?
Dass Nokia zum Beispiel diesen Emulator nur für Windows rausbringt.
Was mich jetzt so ein bisschen überrascht ist, J2ME ist die Mobile Edition von Java.
Genau, da fehlen Apis, aber es sind auch welche dazugekommen. Und dieser Power Player, der ist halt für um Spiele auf dem Mac laufen zu lassen. Und da fehlen halt zum Beispiel die Server Sockets. Also du kannst zwar einen Client Socket in diesem Emulator machen, aber keinen Server Socket, weil der einfach nicht implementiert ist.
Aber wenn jetzt dieses J2ME auch nur GPL ist, ist es doch. Wie ist es?
Das weiß ich nicht hundert Prozent. Also da gab es, glaube ich, noch ein Fragezeichen.
Da gab es Fragezeichen. Hast du vorhin nicht gesagt, es ist alles...
Nee, nee, das war nur J2SI, was ich da meinte.
22. Das ist alles irgendwie... und heißt jetzt Phone MI, um die Konfusion komplett zu machen.
Nee, es kann durchaus sein, dass es vorher auch schon so hieß, weil es von einer Firma, die KVM war, die Virtual Machine.
Hier steht ja auch Supported Platforms. Jetzt werden wir wieder alle vorwürfen. Ich mache hier einen Apple-Podcast drauf. Das ist nun mal mein Computer hier. Und deswegen interessiert mich das. Hier steht aber irgendwie nichts davon. Also mich wundert das so ein bisschen, dass Supported Platforms, sei Linux ARM, Linux x86 und Windows i3-86, das verstehe ich halt irgendwie nicht. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, was da an so einem System, was im Wesentlichen aus Weglassen von Features besteht, was es unmöglich macht, das jetzt auch auf so einer nicht-mobilen Plattform zu laufen zu kriegen.
Also das Linux-mobile SDK, das konnte man auch auf dem Mac zum Laufen bringen, weil das auch halt, der Emulator war auch in Java geschrieben, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Aber man musste sich da schon noch ein bisschen verrenken, um den zum Laufen zu kriegen. Sie haben es halt einfach nicht supported. Man konnte es wohl irgendwie zum Laufen kriegen, aber es wurde nicht supported. Und dann habe ich das halt so gemacht, ich habe einfach auf einen Knopf gedrückt, bauen, Jar bauen, per Bluetooth an meinen Telefon schicken, auf dem Telefon zwei Knöpfe gedrückt, und dann war es halt installiert, und dann konnte ich es auf dem Telefon debuggen.
Ich meine, vielleicht kannst du ja noch mal diesen Prozess beschreiben, aber ich finde das jetzt ganz interessant. Also Java-Software für Server-Backends zu entwickeln, da hat man alle möglichen Tools, das haben wir schon gesehen, das läuft irgendwie auf jedem System, alles prima, alles super, alles zutschert. IDE gibt es irgendwie, alles dicke, fette Tinte, und für Mobile, was jetzt irgendwie sehr viel mehr Installationen am Ende sogar sind, Java-mäßig, rein von der Stückzahl her, kommt man irgendwie keinen Schritt weiter. Also warum ist sowas...
Na, für Linux und Windows gibt es das mobile SDK, problemlos, nur für den Mac halt nicht.
Apple hat da ja auch keinen...
Na ja, es gibt es für Linux x86, ja, also es ist ja hier auch auf einem Prozessor festgelegt. Wenn ich jetzt einen Linux auf einem anderen Plattform festlege, habe ich ja genau das... Okay, es gibt Linux ARM und es gibt Linux x86, aber was ist mit PowerPC, Mipstra? Okay, jetzt kommen natürlich wieder alle und sagen, oh, gibt es ja alles gar nicht mehr. Ich meine, entweder es ist Open Source, und dann läuft es überall, oder nicht. Ich verstehe das irgendwie nicht, aber du hast auch keine gute Antwort. Das macht ja auch nichts. Was mich jetzt interessiert, ist, wie programmiert man dafür? Also, wie stellt man jetzt fest bei so einer Mobile-Edition? Was weiß ich, wie groß ist das Display? Welche Tasten gibt es hier? Hat man da überhaupt eine Chance, daran zu kommen? Oder muss man wissen, worauf man läuft? Und dann muss man ein Programm für das jeweilige Telefon machen?
Man kann es abfragen über Properties. Kann man gucken, bei welchem Hersteller bin ich? Welche Device-Configuration habe ich gerade? Es gibt aber auch da Frameworks. J2ME Polish heißt eins, was ich mal ein bisschen oberflächlich betrachtet habe. Und da gibt es Datenbanken. Die haben eine Device-Datenbank. Du kannst einen Source-Code bauen mit J2ME Polish für verschiedene Telefone. Nämlich für alle, die in deren Datenbank sind. Da gibt es dann welche, die ein gemeinsames Jar haben hinterher und welche, die ein unterschiedliches haben. Und da wird dir das sozusagen abgenommen, um herauszufinden, wie viele Pixel du hast. Also es gibt da Frameworks, die davon abstrahieren von den verschiedenen Telefonen. Wie gut das dann funktioniert, kann ich nicht sagen, weil ich habe nur auf dem Textmodus gearbeitet. Und bin einfach davon ausgeregelt, dass ich mindestens drei Zeilen habe. Und dass ich sozusagen eine Liste machen kann. Und die Liste wird dann halt dargestellt. Und dann kann man durch die Liste durchnavigieren mit dem Stick. Also das ist schon die Minimalkonfiguration. Das reicht schon aus, um so Applikationen wie einen RSS-Reader zu machen. Nur, dass man halt dann die Webseiten, die kann man nicht in diesem Reader gleich darstellen. Sondern da gibt es aber auch eine Standardschnittstelle. Da gibt es einen Call, den man macht. Und dann wird der Standardbrowser auf dem Telefon mit der URL gestartet, die man diesem Call gibt. Und so kann man halt aus dem RSS-Browser dann in den Web-Browser wechseln. Und dann wird da die Seite angezeigt. Also das ging schon.
Also man kann das durchaus hinbekommen.
Und was zum Beispiel ganz cool ist, was mir jetzt gerade gefallen ist, man kann auch per SMS notifiziert werden. Und man kann das Programm, da kann man einen Hook, dem Betriebssystem sagen, ich möchte geweckt werden, wenn auf Port 5000 eine SMS ankommt. Und dann wird das eigene Programm gestartet, wenn so eine SMS auf einen bestimmten Port ankommt. Also es gibt bei SMSen auch Ports, auf die die kommen können. Und dann wird dieses Programm gestartet.
Wie schicke ich denn einen SMSer an einen Port?
Da musst du Tobias fragen. Aber er wollte es für mich einbauen, vielleicht macht er es noch.
Mit meinem Telefon kann ich das machen?
Nee, mit dem Telefon kannst du das glaube ich nicht machen. Aber die Anwendung kann es dann machen. Die J2ME-Anwendung kann dann auch einen Port auf einem anderen Telefon adressieren und dann eine SMS hinschicken. Und das ist ein ganz cooles Feature, weil die abgekratzt werden. Die muss dann halt nicht laufen, sondern sie wird gestartet. Oder sie kriegt halt die Notifizierung, wenn sie schon läuft, kriegt sie halt die SMS reingereicht sozusagen.
Werden die vielleicht anders abgerechnet?
Wer weiß.
Das ist bestimmt teurer. Das ist bestimmt teurer. Da kriegst du bestimmt noch mal eine extra Auflösung deiner Mobilfunkrechnung um die SMS, 29 Cent. Und dann so Port 5000 kosten dann auch 5000 Cent. Das glaubst du nicht. Ich hab auf meiner Mobilfunkrechnung schon so viele bekloppte Scheiße gesehen, ich glaub denen gar nichts. Wie auch immer. Ja. Die Java-Realität. Was sind denn so... Ich meine, jetzt haben wir viel Gutes gehört. Ich will jetzt nicht so sehr drauf rumhacken. Aber es klang ja vorhin auch schon bei unserem Vorgespräch so ein bisschen an. Ist auch nicht alles Gold, was glänzt in der Java-Welt. Was sind denn so die Schwierigkeiten, die ihr seht, mit der Java-Platform, so im täglichen Miteinander zwischen Programmierer und seinem Code?
Du hattest viel mehr als ich. Ich muss nochmal überlegen.
Also naja, es gibt natürlich ein paar Schmuddelecken in den Standard-Libraries. Das bleibt ja auch nicht aus. Bei einer Entwicklungsgeschichte von Java ist es irgendwie früher 90er, dass da halt mal am Anfang nicht alles perfekt gemacht wird. Und da es dann eben sehr viel Wert auf Rückwärtskompatibilität gelegt hat, sind die halt auch oft nicht aufgeräumt worden oder sind einfach noch da. So ein Klassiker ist immer die Behandlung von Datumsangaben. Also diese Java-Date-Klasse, die irgendwie mit Jahreszahlen von 1900 nicht klarkommt und so. Und so Dinge. Ja, genau, da kann man sich irgendwie schön in die Nesseln setzen, wenn man damit zu tun hat.
Und auch Zeitzonen gar nicht kennt. Oder Zeitzonen kennt sie vielleicht gerade noch. Aber da war irgendwie ein ganz anderes, total simples Ding, dieses Date. Deshalb haben sie Gregorian Calendar dann erfunden, was aber einfach nur umständlich ist.
Genau, das war dann der Versuch, das dann total zu abstrahieren. Man kann damit arbeiten, aber es ist halt in einem täglichen Umgang einfach sehr unhandlich. Das war dann die Lösung. Das war eine Baustelle, also Datums- und Zeitformate. Wofür Java eigentlich bekannt ist, nämlich Nebenläufigkeit war ursprünglich. Und Multi-Shredding und so weiter war ursprünglich nicht so toll gelöst. Es ist eigentlich erst ab wann kamen diese Concurrent-Klassen dazu, 1.3, 1.4 und so was.
Da wurde es bequemer und da wurde es auch nochmal komplett überarbeitet. Ich glaube, es hat vorher auch einfach nicht richtig funktioniert.
Genau, genau.
Aber wir hatten Multi-Shredding.
Man hatte Multi-Shredding. Es gab noch nicht mal richtige Log-Objekte. Man hat also beliebige Objekte genommen und die als Log verwendet, was ja erstmal sehr bequem aussieht, aber auch den kleinen hässlichen Nachteil hat, dass jeder, der dieses Objekt haphaft werden kann, das Log blockieren kann. Mit entsprechenden fatalen Wirkungen, gerade wenn man einen Anwendungs-Server hat vielleicht auch. Solche Geschichten, das sind so in den APIs. Gibt es immer mal so Schmuddelecken. Dann soll auch nicht verschwiegen werden, du hast vorhin schon mal die Java-Versionshülle angesprochen, nicht wahr, wenn ich im Applikations-Server bin und vielleicht möchten meine beiden Anwendungen irgendwelche inkompatiblen Versionen von einem XML-Parser, da kann man irgendwie in Probleme, schöne Probleme laufen, die sollen aber auf dem, auf derselben Serverfarm dann laufen oder so, ja, und dann clasht da irgendwas, da kann man in Probleme laufen, da kann man Java auch richtig hassen lernen, wenn man das zu tun hat.
Achso, man kann ja nicht zwei verschiedene Versionen der selben Library gleichzeitig nutzen.
Doch, über verschiedene Classloader kann man das schon machen, aber das mit den, wie werden die Klassen geladen, das ist auch ein Problem für sich. Und man kann schon das in dem Surflot-Container kann man das schon trennen. Wenn man zum Beispiel einen XML-Parser aus dem JDK nicht haben will, sondern eine neuere Version, dann wird es schwierig, weil der wird in jedem Fall vorher schon geladen und der ist dann schon da.
Der Namensraum ist dann sozusagen auch belegt und man kann dann keinen anderen aufmachen? Na doch, man kann nicht jetzt eine andere Library laden und sagen, du bist jetzt mein XML-Parser?
Mit den Sachen, die aus dem JDK kommen, geht das, soweit ich weiß, nicht.
Geht das nicht, nee. Man spricht die Klassen explizit an, aber das ist dann auch irgendwie hässlich. Das will man ja gerade nicht. Man möchte ja gerade diese ganzen Abstraktionsschichten benutzen, die das JDK zur Verfügung stellt für die verschiedenen APIs.
Also wenn was im JDK drin ist, dann kann es einem in die Quere kommen, wenn man es nicht benutzen will.
Tja, und die andere Seite ist natürlich die Sprache in ihrer Eingeschränktheit. Wobei wir da ja heute auch schon ein bisschen gesprochen haben über die Möglichkeiten, auf dynamische Sprachen auszuweichen oder vielleicht sogar eine andere statisch getippte Sprache wie Scala zu verwenden. Aber Java als Sprache selber ist schon ein bisschen, das ist schon so ein bisschen wie mit Händen hinter dem Rücken programmieren.
Was sind denn so deine Kritikpunkte daran?
Was sind so die Kritikpunkte? Na ja, also der erste und der Hauptpunkt ist natürlich das Fehlen von anonymen Funktionen, wie man sie irgendwie aus Lisp sowieso oder aus der funktionalen Programmierung sowieso kennt oder eben auch aus den meisten Skript-Sprachen, die ja sowas irgendwie haben.
Kannst du das mal ein bisschen erläutern? Weil das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen so ein Basiswort und die Standardreaktion ist, das braucht man ja gar nicht. Wieso braucht man das? Also ich meine, warum wird das Leben schöner, wenn man das hat?
Na, weil man sehr, man kann sehr viele Programmier-Algorithmen sehr schön ausdrücken, sehr viele, also eine anonyme Funktion ist einfach, ich kann ein Stückchen Code nehmen, ja, das schreibe, das kann ich quasi zur Laufzeit als Objekt erzeugen, das muss keinen Namen haben, das kann ich halt wie ein Objekt behandeln, in eine Variable speichern, an irgendwelche anderen Funktionen übergeben, die nicht wissen, aus welcher Klasse das kommt, was für eine Funktion das überhaupt ist, und die können das dann einfach an irgendeiner anderen Stelle später aufrufen, das heißt, ich kann irgendeinen abstrakten Algorithmus haben, der eine bestimmte Dinge tut, und an irgendeiner Stelle soll er jetzt irgendwas ausführen, und das kann ich ihm von ganz außen hereinreichen, ja, die einzigartige...
Aber warum ist das besser? Also ich meine, Beispiele. Was, also wo wachsen die Blumen höher, und wo gibt's mir Sauerstoff in der Luft, weil ich eine anonyme Funktion habe?
Also zum Beispiel beim Exception Handling ist das von Vorteil, oder beim Resource Management, man kann in dieser Clojure, also das ist doch Clojure, was meinst du? Da kann ich sagen, hier mache ich das File auf, dann führe ich das aus, was ich ausführen will, und dann mache ich es zu, und wenn eine Exception auftritt, dann mache ich es halt auch zu, und das kapselt man sozusagen in dieser Funktion, und diese Funktion kann man dann an anderer Stelle aufrufen, und muss ich keine Gedanken darüber mehr machen, dass auch das Fall wirklich geschlossen wird, die Ressource wirklich freigegeben wird, weil das halt automatisch vor und nach dem passiert, was in diesem Aufruf dann passiert.
Und was macht man dann in Java stattdessen?
Na, Java benutzt man die sogenannten anonymen inneren Klassen. Das hat man so als Hack dafür eingebührt. Das heißt, ich erzeuge statt einer Funktion eine Klasse, die eine bestimmte Methode mit einem vor vereinbarten Namen je nach Anwendungsfall hat, mit bestimmten Parametern. Und im Prinzip ist das wie eine anonyme Funktion, nur mit einem ziemlich hässlichen Syntax-Overhead, den man hat. Weil man muss halt eine Klasse schreiben und den Namen der Methode und so. Und ja, das ist unhandlich einfach. Es macht schnell, gerade wenn sich das dann schachtelt vielleicht, dass man in einer anonymen Funktion auch nochmal eine anonyme Funktion erzeugen möchte oder solche Dinge. Das wird schon, denn man kriegt schnell eine hohe Schachtelungstiefe einfach im Syntax. Und es ist dann sehr unpraktisch, das zu lesen als auch zu schreiben.
Und man hat dann Semikodons und geschliesene Klammern an Stellen, wo man überhaupt nicht damit rechnet.
Ich sage mal, woran ich mich noch erinnern kann, dass es mich extrem gestört hat bei Java. Vielleicht stört euch das ja nicht so sehr, aber was mich so gestört hat, ist, dass es einerseits diese Typen aus C gibt, sowas wie int, und dann gibt es halt die Objektypen. Und dass das irgendwie nicht das Gleiche ist, dass man es im Prinzip mit zwei Arten von Variablen zu tun hat, die man eben nicht beliebig mischen kann.
Das ist auch der Historie zu verdanken, weil int und long, also die Basistypen, die waren halt damals schneller. Die bräuchte man jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr, aber die kann man auch nicht wegschmeißen, weil die immer noch benutzt werden. Und in manchen Fällen sind sie sogar überlegen, den Objektypen, weil sie nämlich atomar geschrieben werden. Also long und double nicht, aber int und float und booleans werden atomar geschrieben. Also da kannst du ja sicher sein, da kommt keiner dazwischen während diese Variablegeschichte. Bei einem boolean ist das in gewisser Hinsicht auch logisch, weil da kann man kaum dazwischen funken. Aber das ist halt historisch bedingt. Das ist sozusagen Pech.
Aber es ist scheiße, oder?
Es ist Mist, klar.
Es ist unschön, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so... Also gut, mit Autoboxing kann man auch wieder in neue Probleme laufen, weil dann ist plötzlich... Also Autoboxing ist so die Konvertierung zwischen diesen Basis... Die heißen nicht Basistypen.
Ich nenne die auch so.
Zwischen Basistypen und demselben Objektyp gibt es einen Mechanismus, der die automatisch hin- und herkonvertiert, je nachdem, wie es gerade gebraucht wird. Aber das kann wiederum auch zu Problem sein.
Duffer Tape, Heißkleber und Kabelbinder sozusagen.
Das passiert dann vielleicht an Stellen, wo man das gar nicht will. Dann hat man einen schönen Performance-Overhead. Plötzlich lauter solche Effekte am Hals. Ja, das ist der Historie geschuldet. Und man lernt es richtig hassen, wenn man Reflection-Code schreibt. Dann muss man unter Umständen immer eine Fallunterscheidung machen. Ist das jetzt der Basistyp oder ist das der gewreppte Typ usw. Da verlässt einen dann die ganze Reflection-Logik. Da hat man dann richtig zu leiden. Da kann Java auch richtig schmerzen. Dann fehlen so schöne Niceties, die sich in anderen Sprachen durchgesetzt haben. Was man von Python kennt, Generator-Expressions. Das ist im Java-Land nie angekommen. Das wäre wünschenswert, wenn sich da mal etwas tun würde. Eine Generator-Expression ist, wenn ich sehr einfach und elegant eine Liste erzeugen kann mit bestimmten Werten. Ohne dass ich jetzt einen groß empirativen Code schreiben kann. Ich kann mir so etwas schreiben wie, gib mir jetzt mal eine Liste, wo immer abwechselnd Quadratzahlen und Kubikzahlen stehen. Das kann ich dann sehr elegant, deklarativ, in der Sprache wie Python hinschreiben, während ich in Java die richtig manuell aufbauen müsste mit einer richtig schön klassischen Vorschleife. Das ist ein nütziges Pattern, das sich im Großen und Ganzen durchgesetzt hat. Alle modernen Programmiersprachen bauen das irgendwann mal ein Jahr. Das ist in Java einfach nicht da. Das ist eigentlich nicht so richtig zu sehen, warum es das nicht gibt.
Heißt das, dass der Java, also ich meine, habt ihr das Gefühl, dass Java noch weiterentwickelt wird? Oder hat sich das jetzt ein bisschen festgefressen? Wir haben bisher mal gehört, in der Version kam das, in der Version kam das. Es sieht ja schon so aus, als ob von Version zu Version eine Menge passiert.
Also Closures sind jetzt gerade in der Diskussion. Zwei verschiedene Arten, Closures zu machen. Oder eben doch keine. Also die drei Varianten gibt es jetzt gerade. Also man könnte auch sagen, wir machen jetzt mal Schluss mit Java. Und jetzt bleibt es so, wie es ist. Und wir konzentrieren uns lieber auf andere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel Scala oder Groovy. Oder auch, naja, J-Ruby wird ja von anderen getragen.
Könnte man nicht auch einfach so ein, was weiß ich, Turbo-Java machen, wo man sagt, jetzt schmeißen wir mal die Basis-Typen raus und alles andere, was irgendwie alt ist. Aber eigentlich ist es so.
Ja, also es gibt auch, wenn Java 3 kommt, dass es dann nicht mehr rückwärts, also gibt es auch Diskussionen, soll es dann nicht mehr rückwärts kompatibel sein.
Ja, aber wenn es in der gleichen VM läuft, dann musst du sicher nicht unbedingt beißen, oder?
Es ist halt ein schwieriges Feld. Einerseits ist halt Java erfolgreich immer gewesen wegen der Rückwärtskompatibilität. Andererseits muss man halt sagen, wenn man mal wirklich in der Sprache aufräumen wollen würde, dann würde man größere Änderungen halt auch im JDK, nicht im JDK, in den Standardbibliotheken nach sich ziehen. Dann würde man halt plötzlich, wenn jetzt Clashers eingeführt würden, bräuchte man diese ganzen anonymen inneren Klassen nicht mehr theoretisch. Dann hat man halt plötzlich das Problem, wenn man rückwärtskompatibel bleiben will, hat man also einen Wildwuchs an Mechanismen, wo man immer nicht weiß, wann ist jetzt welcher angebracht. Und die Alternative ist, man räumt halt auf und dann geht der ganze alte Code nicht mehr.
Das kann man sich im Grunde nicht erlauben.
Das kann man sich nicht erlauben. Eigentlich müssen wir alles neu schreiben. Eigentlich müssen wir alles neu schreiben, aber ja, gut.
Das ist manchmal auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber vielleicht ist es dann tatsächlich sinnvoller, jetzt zu sagen, mit Java ist jetzt mal hier Ende, da kommt nichts Neues mehr. Also das wäre, glaube ich, mein Ansatz, zu sagen, Java, vielleicht noch Closures, noch Reihen, und dann ist aber erst mal Schluss. Na, andere Sprachen pushen.
Mit derselben VM.
Und vor allen Dingen, es gibt ja jetzt auch vielleicht demnächst Bytecode-Instruktionen, die für...
Also andere Sprachen auf derselben VM, in derselben Plattform, so wie Groovy.
Genau, dass halt die JVM weiterentwickelt wird. Also Invoke Dynamic ist so ein Ding, was vielleicht kommen wird. Das braucht Java überhaupt nicht, aber die dynamischen Sprachen, da gibt es auch unterschiedliche Ansichten, ob sie es brauchen oder nicht. Aber das wäre die erste Instruktion im Bytecode, die nicht für Java eingebaut wird, wo Java nichts davon hat. Und das ist die Richtung, glaube ich, die funktionieren kann, dass man eben... Java ist wirklich das Kobol von heute. Und jeder kann seinen ganzen alten Scheiß da weiter drauf laufen lassen. Aber die coolen Typen, die gehen halt irgendwie zu Groovy oder Scala oder...
Das sieht ja auch so aus, als ob sozusagen die Java-Randheim eigentlich so das Herz aus Gold ist. Dass das eigentlich wirklich so der Bahnhof ist, wo sich alle treffen. Ja, das Asset der Plattform.
Naja, ich weiß nicht. Die Nutzbarkeit der Plattform steht und fällt eben auch sehr stark mit den Standardbibliotheken. Und da sehe ich eben genau das Problem der Evolution einfach, weil man die nicht vernünftig, sagt man evolieren, weiterentwickeln kann, wenn man, wenn man halt auf der Sprache eben neue Dinge machen möchte. Und da ist die Schwierigkeit.
Das ist richtig.
Aber performance-mäßig kann er noch so einiges tun. Hier war bei Car's Radio Express in letzter Zeit schon häufiger mal davon die Rede von LLVM. Ist einer von euch da mit vertraut mit dem Projekt.
Ich habe sie noch im Mac-Mobile-Podcast.
Ja, da haben wir das auch schon erwähnt. Ich hoffe auch, da irgendwann nochmal was ausführlicheres zu machen. Aber ich habe bisher noch niemanden gefunden, der jetzt wirklich da gnadenlos im Detail Auskunft geben kann. Aber nur so als Randnotiz. LLVM, also LLVM ist ja diese Modulsammlung Compilerbau, wo alle möglichen Ebenen der Coderzeugung komplett neu angedacht werden. Wo man halt eine sehr schnelle VM hat, eben diese Low-Level-Virtual Machine. Und die neueste Version von LLVM, die jetzt vor kurzem rausgekommen ist, die 2.3, bringt halt auch eine Java-VM in LLVM.
Ah, das VM-Kit, ne?
Genau, das VM-Kit hat mehrere VMs. Und eine der VMs ist halt das. Das heißt, da tut sich einfach doch eine ganze Menge. Also im Bereich der Implementierung der Java-VM. Einfach, weil natürlich eben die Code-Basis so enorm groß ist. Von daher werden wir da, glaube ich, noch so einige sehen. Na gut, aber jetzt bewegen wir uns so langsam in die Deutung und Wunschwelt. Da will ich jetzt nicht hängen bleiben. Was mich jetzt schon nochmal ein bisschen interessiert ist, die Server-Seite. Jetzt haben wir ja schon tausendmal erwähnt, dass das ja eigentlich nur die Stärke ist. Jetzt haben wir noch nicht so sehr viel darüber geredet. Insbesondere so jetzt im Web. Also du hast schon mal diese Surflets angesprochen. Gibt es denn da noch andere Frameworks und Infrastrukturen? Also es gibt auf jeden Fall noch welche, aber welche sollte man jetzt sozusagen noch erwähnen? Also Tomcat ist mal gefallen. Das sind ja alles so bekanntere Namen in der Java-Welt. Könnt ihr das mal so ein bisschen auseinanderruppen? Was setzt man auf, wenn man so eine Server-Infrastruktur hat? Also was läuft da?
Verschiedene Richtungen. Also das eine ist halt, was du halt ansprichst, halt die Servlet-Umgebung. Und da gibt es halt neben Tomcat, wie heißt hier, Jetty oder so, da gibt es auch die ganzen Commerz-Resin und...
Das sind halt Servlet-Container. Da kann man ein Servlet reintun und der...
Und dann läuft das Servlet in diesem Container auf. Und die unterscheiden sich durch unterschiedliche Features und Performance-Daten. Sind die alle kompatibel zu anderen?
Ja, genau. Das ist erst mal der Punkt.
Die gehorchen alle der Servlet-RP-Spezifikation.
Und die ist auch so halbwegs stabil?
Ja, die...
Erinnert sich nicht mehr oder doch?
Doch, da gibt es immer mal wieder eine neue Version. Aber man kann mit 2.3 schon sehr weit kommen. Und inzwischen ist es, glaube ich, bei 2.5 oder so. Also da tut sich nicht so viel, dass man damit Probleme hätte, dass sich so viel getan hat.
Aber noch genug, damit sich das auch der Zukunft anpasst. Okay, verstehe.
Ja, und dann gibt es natürlich die ganzen APs im Enterprise-Bereich. AGB haben wir schon mal angesprochen. Vielleicht noch mal ein anderer, der weniger bekannt ist, ist das Java-Messaging. Der Java-Messaging-Bereich. Also wenn man halt größere Unternehmensanwendungen... Man hat irgendwie eine Bank, die haben irgendwie 500 Legacy-Anwendungen im Laufe ihrer Existenz gekauft und die sollen irgendwie in einer Infrastruktur zusammengebunden werden, dann ist halt so ein sehr üblicher Ansatz, dass man die mit irgendwelchen Message-Bussen zusammenknotet. Die Anwendungen werden mit einem sogenannten Konverter mit dem Message-Busssystem verbunden und können dann ihre Informationen über dieses Bussystem untereinander austauschen. Und in dem Bussystem findet dann Routing statt und Konvertierung. Und darüber kriegt man die halt dazu, miteinander zu sprechen, ohne dass man jetzt von jeder Anwendung zu jeder anderen Anwendung irgendwelche Plugins schreiben muss, was halt ein nicht vertretbarer Aufwand wäre. Und da gibt es eben auch nochmal eine ganze Menge an Dingen, die halt jeweils dieses Java-Messaging-API implementieren. Also so klassiker ist es natürlich so was wie MQ-Series von IBM, das ist ja bekannt. Aber da gibt es auch eine ganze Menge weiterer Hersteller, die sowas auch implementieren. Das ist jetzt nicht so die Webschiene, das ist halt eher wirklich im Backend von größeren Unternehmen. Und da spielt aber Java eben auch eine sehr, sehr wichtige Rolle. Weil das ein großes Problem ist. Wenn man halt so einen Haufen Legacy-Anwendungen hat, die kriegt man nicht so schnell, die sind nicht so einfach miteinander integriert ohne Support-Infrastruktur.
Aber diese Enterprise Edition, also was bringt die denn jetzt mit sich im Gegensatz zu dieser Standard Edition? Braucht man dann überhaupt noch was dazu? Sind das jetzt hier so extra Gadgets oder kommt man damit irgendwie auch schon klar?
Also bei J2EE ist auf jeden Fall Surflet, EJB dabei, JMS, weiß ich gar nicht genau, ob JMS auch dazugehört.
Das hat sich irgendwann mal geändert, das war nicht gleich dabei.
Was ist JMS?
Das, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Dann gibt es vielleicht, ich kenne auch nicht die ganze Plattform JMX, gibt es vielleicht noch was dazugehört, Management von Java-Containern sozusagen, da kann man sowieso ein leichter Debugger, also man piekt da rein und lässt sich dann den Status irgendwie, welche Methoden haben wie lange gebraucht und warum ist mein Backend so langsam und das kann man über JMX steuern und auch sagen.
So eine Art Fieberthermometer, so ein Fernbeschluss.
Genau, Fieberthermometer und aber auch Eingriffsmöglichkeit, um Sachen zu ändern, also Management halt, Management-Konsole, kann man dazu glaube ich sagen. Und da gibt es auch noch eine Debugger-Schnittstelle, aber wir waren jetzt bei J2I, ne?
Ich glaube, bestimmte Teile von Java-Mail sind auch in IE mit drin.
Aber im Prinzip ist es so, man kann sich diese Enterprise-Edition runterleihen, ballert die irgendwie auf seinen Server und dann kann man da Surflets reinwerfen und die laufen einfach so. Braucht man da noch, was ist Tomcat?
Tomcat ist ein Surflet-Container, aber inzwischen auch noch mehr.
Ja, aber braucht man den jetzt noch zusätzlich oder ist der Teil von J2MI?
Der ist nicht Teil von J2MI, das ist die Apache Tomcat, die Apache-Referenz-Implementierung eines Surflet-Containers.
Aber das EE bringt sowieso da schon mit sich?
Nee, das EE bringt nur die API mit. Also man programmiert seinen Kram gegen die Surflet-API. Und wenn das kompiliert und dann ein Warfell hinten rausfällt, dann kann man das in einen beliebigen Surflet-Container reintun. Und der implementiert dann tatsächlich das, was man vorher sozusagen als Stub angesprochen hat.
Okay, also EE bringt nicht selber einen Surflet-Container mit sich, sondern nur die Voraussetzung, einen Lauf zu lassen.
EE ist die Definition der Schnittstellen, die ein Surflet oder auch ein EJB-Container, der hatte natürlich noch viel mehr zu tun. Also JBoss ist zum Beispiel ein ganz beliebter EJB-2- und EJB-3-Container. Und EJB-2 und EJB-3, da ist der hauptsächliche Unterschied, was ich so gehört habe, dass es sehr viel einfacher geworden ist, weil EJB-2 wohl doch overingeniert war und kaum –also, das kann man nicht sagen, es hat sehr viel Verwendung gefunden, aber es war …Mal in der Zeit, ein paar Schrauben zu drehen. Genau, man hat es verkleinert. In EJB-3 ist es sehr viel verkleinert. Ich glaube, auch Annotations haben da sehr geholfen, dass die gekommen sind.
Genau, richtig. Also umgekehrt glaube ich, die sind eher deswegen gekommen.
Ach so, das kann natürlich auch …Also Annotations heißt, dass du im Source Code Anmerkungen machen kannst, also sogar beliebige Anmerkungen, die in den Class Files hinterher noch drin sind. Und dann gibt es halt Konventionen, was für Anmerkungen man da macht. Zum Beispiel bei Hibernate, das ist ein OR-Mapper, da schreibt man halt rein irgendwie, diese Methode liefert etwas, was persistent sein soll. Oder diese Klasse gehört zu der Tabelle in der Datenbank, die foo heißt.
Und das muss man in seinen Source Code in Kommentare reinschreiben.
Nein, das sind nicht Kommentare, sondern die Notation ist add, Keyword und dann Klammerauf oder auch keine Klammerauf. Und dann schreibt man da seine, es sind halt, ja, Schreibmärkungen.
Das wird dann von dem Compiler mit in die Klasse reingetan. Und wer liest das dann aus?
Zum Beispiel Sachen, die Reflection benutzen, man kann es über Reflection auslesen. Oder halt beim Kompilieren von dem Framework, was dann mit diesen Klassen was macht, kann das auch schon ausgewertet werden.
Das heißt, das ist so eine Art Metadaten über den eigenen Code.
Ja, genau.
Aber warum ist das nötig? Ich meine, was ändert das?
Man kann darüber Konfigurationen beispielsweise machen, die, na gut, Konfiguration ist vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber, ja.
Vielleicht mal ein klasses, also das klassische, modernes Beispiel, sind zum Beispiel Web-Services, die ja irgendwie in der Interpress-Wallet eine gewisse Popularität haben. Dann kann ich zum Beispiel an meine Klasse reinschreiben, diese Klasse soll eine Web-Service-Klasse sein. Und diese Methode soll eine Methode des Web-Services sein. Die anderen Methoden aber bitte nicht. Und dann kann ich vielleicht noch sagen, wie die Parameter dann jetzt in diesem ganzen Zoop-XML-Gesoße dann bitte zu codieren sind und solche Dinge.
Aber ist nicht dafür, diese Interface ist eigentlich schon gedacht gewesen, dass man sagt, das ist hier irgendwie ein Web-Service, und der implementiert das irgendwie richtig?
Ja, aber das muss ja dann noch gemapped werden, weil die Zielspezifikationen, wie halt Web-Services, wie die Protokolle halt aussehen, da hat man ja einen gewissen Mismatch quasi zwischen der Java-Seite und der Spezifikations-Seite, wie Zoop, XML, Schema und so weiter. Und das muss man halt noch ein bisschen zusammenknoten. Da fehlen manchmal noch so ein bisschen Informationen. Dasselbe, was hier Dirk gegeben hat für Datenbanken, wo ich halt sagen möchte, okay, mein String soll aber in der SQL-Datenbank als VAR-Chart 255 dargestellt werden oder sowas.
Das war der OR, den er erwähnt hat, Object Relation Mapper.
Ja, solche Meta-Informationen möchte man halt manchmal hinterlegen. Und das kann auch sehr nützlich sein, weil man kann dann ein Tool schreiben, das entweder das zur Runtime macht im Idealfall oder eben, wenn halt Code generiert wird, wie bei Webservices, vielleicht auch zur Compile-Time, das halt einfach den Code analysiert, sich die Annotationen anguckt und dann eben entsprechende Dinge tut, damit eben nur die Methoden hinterher im Webservice, die als Webservice-Methoden markiert werden, auch von außen aufrufbar sind und die anderen eben nicht, oder so, um das mal ganz einfach darzustellen.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt irgendwie mit Java loslegen will, hat man auf den meisten Plattformen eigentlich schon alles, was man braucht. Man hat irgendwie fast überall mal eben eine Standard-Edition im Zugriff und kann Java-Programme damit laufen lassen. Ist der Compiler da schon dabei? Nee, das JDK muss man separat.
Man lädt das JDK runter und hat dann JRI und Compiler zusammen. Und man hat auch sogar noch einen D-Compiler dabei, wobei der nicht so... also da gibt es bessere.
Ja gut, damit fängt man ja vielleicht nicht gleich an.
Ja, aber wenn man halt eh sozusagen auf die Server-Seite geht, dann nimmt man dann gleich das EE anstatt das SE, und dann hat man irgendwie mehr.
In der Regel...
Ich weiß nicht, versucht man so ein bisschen nachzuvollziehen, wie man sich jetzt so seine Umgebung einrichtet, worauf man als erstes losstößt.
Ich glaube, man lädt sich eher das J2-SI runter, und dann die einzelnen... die Surflat-API halt dazu, wenn man die braucht. Oder die ist... in der Regel hat man die schon in seiner IDE drin.
Ich dachte jetzt, weil es auch Edition heißt, dass es dann sozusagen etwas ist, was man so als solches bekommt.
Ja, nee, also in der Regel fährt man mit dem J2 SDK schon völlig auf der sicheren Seite. Man braucht dann eben nur gegebenenfalls für sein Projekt die passenden Libraries noch dazu aus dem J2 EE. Das ist eher so die Art und Weise, in der man verfährt. Beziehungsweise die IDE oder Maven zieht sie einem. Man kümmert sich da eigentlich gar nicht so doll drum.
Ja, unser Versuch hier so mal einen Java-Überblick zu geben, um so ein bisschen aus der Praxis zu berichten. Jetzt muss ich schon nochmal fragen. Haben wir jetzt irgendwas Wichtiges, was euch noch am Herzen liegt, vergessen? Alles, was wir uns jetzt mal notiert hatten, das ist, glaube ich, alles ganz gut angesprochen worden. Ich habe mittlerweile einen Überblick.
Mal was geschafft. Ich weiß nicht.
Fällt euch jetzt konkret mal was zu ein? Ansonsten wollte ich nämlich mal fragen hier, Frage geht vor allem an Dirk, denke ich mal. Du bist ja auch ein ganz fleißiger Podcast-Hörer und du hörst ja sicherlich auch ein paar Java-spezifische Podcasts. Das ist etwas, was ich in jedem Podcast immer vergesse, die Leute mal nach Podcasts zu fragen zu dem jeweiligen Thema. Aber du kannst doch da sicherlich ein paar Tipps geben, oder?
Ja, ich höre sehr gerne Java-Possi, also javapossi.com. Die erzählen halt so ein bisschen locker. Da ist einer, einer der bei Sun arbeitet, einer der, nee, zwei bei Google und der dritte Navagenics. Die machen irgendwie Genanalyse, aber darum geht es nicht. Sondern es geht halt hauptsächlich um Java, manchmal auch um Bücher zu Java, also alles Mögliche und auch sehr technisch. Also das finde ich gerade ganz gut, dass, ja, dass man, also das ist der einzige Java-Podcast, den ich tatsächlich höre. Ansonsten höre ich noch andere Podcasts.
Die jetzt aber nicht so Java-spezifisch sind.
Genau.
Okay, aber den kannst du auf jeden Fall auch empfehlen. Ist auf Englisch, schätze ich mal. Deutscher hast du nicht entdeckt?
Nein, ich habe noch keinen deutschen Java-Podcast gefunden. Deshalb überlege ich auch schon selber einzumachen. Mal sehen, ob das was wird.
Podcasting Opportunities. Ja, ansonsten würde ich sagen, können wir die Klappe auch fallen lassen, oder? Haben wir noch irgendwie was Wichtiges? Dann sage ich erst mal Danke an Boggle und an Dirk. Und euch, denen es hoffentlich gefallen hat, einen Einblick gegeben hat. Ihr könnt euch auch wieder fleißig beteiligen bei uns im Web-Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de, wozu jeder Sendung gerade in der letzten Zeit eine Myriade an Kommentaren aufschlägt. Und ich bitte dann auch immer alle Gäste dann doch noch mal eine Weile reinzuschauen. Und gegebenenfalls ein paar Nachfragen zu machen. Das ist natürlich jetzt hier auch wieder so ein Thema, wo ich schon vorher wusste, dass wir danach aber Millionen Hinweise bekommen werden, mit ihr hättet aber noch hmmm und darüber und warum habt ihr denn das nicht erwähnt? Und ihr seid ja doof. Und das war alles ganz falsch. Ich weiß es viel besser. Das stimmt. Ja, das stimmt. Aber bevor wir hier über Java-Aspekte weiterreden können, muss man überhaupt erstmal eine Grundlage legen und ich hoffe, das haben wir jetzt hier so halbwegs mitgemacht, einen Überblick zu bekommen über die Java-Welt und wie es so ist als Programmierer, an welche Schmerzen man so zu erleiden hat. Und mal gucken, vielleicht gehen wir ja in Zukunft nochmal das eine oder andere spezifischere Java-Thema direkt an. Da ist sicherlich so einiges zu holen und die Plattform hat viel zu viel Einfluss an so vielen Stellen, dass man das jetzt wegignorieren könnte. Bei Chaos Radio Express oder an anderen Stellen? Ja, und ich sage danke Dirk, danke Boggle, danke fürs Zuhören. Das war es mit Chaos Radio Express. Wir sagen jetzt alle schönartig Tschüss. Und bis bald zur nächsten Ausgabe vom CRE.